tkinter can help you create GUI apps
with python quickly and easily and with
the ttk bootstrap Library it's simple to
make your tkinter apps look amazing in
this course John Elder will teach you
how to use ttk bootstrap he will show
you how to use all the main widgets to
make your decanter apps look modern and
awesome what's going on guys John Alder
here from tcincture.com and in this
video I'm going to talk about modern tea
kinter design with ttk bootstrap
all right guys like I said in this video
we're going to look at modern GUI design
with something called ttk bootstrap now
I've talked about different sort of
modern libraries out there in the past
custom ttk for instance this is a little
bit different this is very complete and
very robust whereas custom ttk is still
kind of new in getting some of the Kinks
worked out of it works great but still
doesn't support all the widgets and
things like this this supports all the
widgets and then some adds some new ones
it's really cool but before we get
started be sure to grab your totally
free PDF copy of my Kinder widget quick
reference guidebook thing is awesome
over 150 pages with all the Kinder
widget attributes grab your free copy
today just head over to tkenter.com
forward slash widget-book enter your
email address and I'll send that right
out to you so this is ttk bootstrap and
if you're familiar with bootstrap it's a
CSS framework for websites it's probably
one of the most popular CSS Frameworks
in fact if you go to getbootstrap.com
you can see you know here's a page on
bootstrap buttons for instance you have
this sort of very distinct look to
things if you look at nav bars you know
you can have nav bars for websites very
distinct looking thing one of the most
popular CSS Frameworks on the internet
so basically what this package does is
it takes that and sort of applies it to
kinter which is very cool so you can see
I've got just a couple of examples
pulled up here this is a dark theme
there's dark themes and light themes so
you can see very cool the buttons here
in fact let's try and there we go zoom
in a little bit so you can see there's
like dashes around the buttons you can
have outlines or solid these things look
more modern these things look more
modern your check boxes and your toggle
switches look better even the entry
widgets and the spin boxes look better
the date picker looks cool very cool so
you can see there's all kinds of
different themes to choose from
this one's called Vapor it's very
purpley uh you can check out the light
themes
there's a bunch of them
very cool
flatly
Journal
litera
and what's great about this is you could
pick a theme or you can build your own
and there's resources here to actually
build your own theme so we'll get into
all that in the future minty right pulse
Samsung so in this video I want to just
sort of walk you through what this is
how you can get started and all the good
things so just head over to
ttkbootstrap.readthedocs.io and if you
click on getting started this is how you
pip install it just your regular pip
install ttk bootstrap from your terminal
we'll get it done in fact if we head
over to our terminal I could just pip
install gtk bootstrap and that's really
all we need to do
boom boom and it's ready to go so if we
click on the tutorial here and kind of
look into this using it is very simple
it's very much like using your regular
kinter widgets so what you're going to
do is you're going to come here and when
you import this thing it the docs are
telling you to import ttk bootstrip as
ttk I don't recommend that you do that
because you know we use ttk stuff for
other things the dtk library that comes
with kenter
I don't think you want to name it that
so I would name it something like
uh TB or something to tkinter bootstrap
or
ttk be something like that just to
distinguish it as bootstrap and not ttk
but you could do it as ttk if you want
like the docs say you also want to
import these I'll talk about those in a
second here and if we come down here to
use these things a regular button we
would just call a button well instead of
that you call attk or ttkb whatever you
named it up here
button right and then instead of giving
it a style like you would with your
widget you give it a boot style so
instead of using style for all your
widgets you use boot style that's really
kind of the only thing and you can see
they're using these constants here we've
imported these constants you can also
use different things you can use
quotation marks like we've done in
regular videos all the time in fact you
can see you know you can see you could
use quotation marks with dashes without
dashes with
with spaces without spaces with commas
without commas or just the constant
capital letters whatever you feel
comfortable with so that's kind of nice
and really that's sort of all there is
to it everything else is just like using
bootstrap as normal for the most part so
when you start it you could create a
regular root TK instance or you could
use a window instance which is slightly
different and they kind of recommend so
we would probably use that like I said
we're going to get into this in the next
few videos we're going to start building
stuff out with this in this video I just
want to kind of give you a very brief
overview and to pick a theme it's just
as easy as whenever you either if you
use a window instance you just pass in
the theme equals and then the name of
the theme or if you use the regular old
way of doing it you just create a style
equals ttk.style and then pass in the
name like I said we're going to probably
be using this window thing going forward
when we use this but we'll get into all
that later and that's kind of all there
is to it now if you come up here to the
top and look at the style guide you can
see see all of the different things you
could do with this so right off the bat
the colors that this offers are the
basic bootstrap colors this sort of blue
green light blue orange red light and
dark right I'm sure you can override
those but those are the basic ones that
come with bootstrap right so if you've
used bootstrap on websites you're
familiar with this color scheme already
very cool and I'm just going to go
through here and show you what these all
look like so the check buttons these are
the basic check buttons very cool the
combo box much more modern looking date
entry
a little calendar picker tool very cool
there's a date picker pop-up with a
calendar very awesome right just your
regular entry box you could colorize and
do things with that's cool there's this
flood gauge which is not in regular
kinter right sort of a progress bar
buttony looking thing very cool right
just one of the few things that are
extra in this over regular kinter it's
got your basic frame it's got your basic
label your basic label frame
right but you can colorize these label
frames which is very cool
yeah you know menu buttons look better
there's this cool meter right which is
not regular in kinter so that's cool
that's a little extra thing you could
have you can see it has dashes or solid
or whatever very cool notebooks sort of
the tab thing in Pinter
but a little more modern looking a paint
window
move those around progress bars look
better right
very cool you can also have striped ones
definitely more modern looking right
radio buttons different colors uh you
can have a scale
zoop zoop very nice
irregular scroll bar
a separator the most popular kinter
Widget the separator is just a line uh
size grip where you can like move things
around
ah very cool uh your spin boxes we've
looked at these
preview right boom very more modern much
more modern looking tree views very cool
and then there's some stuff on Legacy
widgets we don't really care all that
much about that so you can click here
and read on the API there's even more
stuff in here so if you want to do a
color Chooser is information on that
there is color drop
dialogue very cool
all kinds of cool stuff in here there's
a regular dialog box font dialog
pop this thing up very useful
message boxes look better right
message dialogue there's a query box
this little thing
very cool just all kinds of stuff you
could look in Styles Colors theme
definitions and there's also a style
Builder right this is a different app
that you need to pip install we'll get
into all that too very cool helps you
build your own Styles and themes and
things like that
I hear some stuff on boot style anyway
all kinds of cool stuff you can look
through here if you're interested we're
going to be going through all of this
because I think this is very cool and
I'm going to be building a bunch of
videos on this in the coming you know
days and weeks probably create a course
on it too but uh very very cool lots of
fun very easy to use and uh definitely
check it out so that's ttk bootstrap
very cool like I said we're going to be
getting into this in the coming videos
and should be a lot of fun and uh I'm
excited
so now we're going to actually dive in
and start learning how to use it so in
this video we're going to do just a very
basic app to get it up and running show
you how to get an app up and running I'm
going to show you how to do labels and
buttons in this video as well as a
little function based on the button so
we can click this and it says goodbye
World hello world Goodbye World hello
world
Etc so very basic but it allow us to see
the different types of buttons we can
use and the different ways you can
configure labels and buttons and all
that good stuff so head over to our code
I'm using the Slime text editor and the
get batch terminal as always I've got a
file I'm just calling it TB underscore
intro PB short for ttk bootstrap I guess
TV whatever and this is our basic kinter
starter code that we would always have
root TK instance you know your icon you
set the size and you've got your main
Loop so your ttk bootstrap app is going
to be a little bit different than that
so first things first we need to make
sure we actually have ttk bootstrap
installed on our system so head over to
your terminal and just pip install ttk
bootstrap I've already got it so it's
gonna be like hey you've already got it
but if you don't it'll go ahead and
install and you should be good to go so
first we need to come up here and import
some things that come with ttk bootstrap
so first it's from ttk
bootstrap dot constants we want to
import everything and I'll show you what
those are in just a second you don't
necessarily have to do this but you may
want to you may not I'll explain what
that means in just a minute so we also
need to import ttk bootstrap itself so
we want to import ttk bootstrap as and
I'm going to call this TB now they
suggest you import it as ttk but if
you're going to use ttk or if you're you
know going to get confused by that I
suggest you just import it as something
else TB short for ttk bootstrap or you
might want to import it as ttkb you know
whatever floats your boat I'm just gonna
go TB it really doesn't matter but you
need to import it as something so that
you can use it so okay in a normal
kinter app you have your TK instance now
you can do that with ttk bootstrap but
they don't suggest that they suggest
something else instead they say you
should go TB dot window and then inside
of here you can pass whatever theme you
want so you can go theme name equals and
I want super hero I'm gonna use the
superhero theme so there are a bunch of
themes you can use head over to the ttk
bootstrap docs that's a
ttkbootstrap.readthedocs.io and you can
come over to themes click either light
or dark I want dark and then here these
are just the themes so if you want solar
you type in solar if you want superhero
you type in superhero Darkly Darkly you
know you get the idea so go ahead and
pick one I've picked superhero I think
that looks kind of cool that's neat now
we can click on style guide we're going
to look at that in just a minute too but
first we can come back over here and if
we just go ahead and save this and run
this again python TB underscore intro.pi
we get an error because I forgot an
equal to sign it looks like yeah right
there so this should be root equals so
now I'll come back over here
give this another try
we have another error man I'm on fire
today this should be ttk boot
strap there we go all right one more
time
we see right off the bat we have a
different color background now when you
pick a specific theme every widget you
use is going to be colored and shaped
and whatever based on that theme so sort
of keep that in mind so let's start out
with a label so I'm going to call this
my underscore label and this is going to
be a TV DOT label and now it's TB here
because we imported this as TB there so
if you import it as something else this
would be whatever you imported it as
same thing up here with the window thing
and these all act pretty much the same
as your basic into your widgets so you
can set the text any way you want I'm
just going to say hello world
you can also set the font in the normal
way that you would so I'm going to say
helvetica and give this a size like 28.
now here's where it gets a little bit
different
you have this boot style attribute here
and this is where you get to pick
whatever however you want to style this
thing so gtk bootstrap comes with the
same basic color scheme that the
bootstrap CSS framework comes with so
let me just copy and paste these in real
quick put these on another line
you have the default primary secondary
success info warning danger light and
dark so light and dark they are how they
sound one's light one's dark the default
is just the default it's usually like
white or something primary is blue
secondary is gray success is green info
is a light blue warning is yellow I
think and danger is red and you could
see these if you want head over to the
style guide and they're listed here so
primer is this dark blue secondary is
gray green sort of light blue yeah
warning is looks like orange I guess and
dangerous red and then light and dark so
those are sort of the colors you can
choose from so let's say let me put this
on another line so we can see this we
could just start out with the default
and see what that looks like now I've
got this in quotation marks and that's
perfectly fine but up here we imported
these constants so if you want you can
use just the constants which are
all capital whatever right I tend to not
do that because I'm used to putting them
in quotes like regular kinter and
regular ttk stuff so I will usually just
go like this and you know do it like
that either way works whatever you're
comfortable with but if you want to use
the constants you have to import them up
there if you don't you don't have to
import it at all so all right let's go
ahead and my underscore label dot pack
this guy and this gives us a pad y of
like 50. you really push it down the
screen so let's save this and run it see
what we have here
and boom we get this hello world in this
sort of default light color now this is
white in default in this theme that
color might be a different color in a
different theme so just sort of keep
that in mind so if you're using a light
themed theme I'm guessing that's
probably going to be black as the
default instead of white so you just
have to play around with your specific
theme to see what's what so we can come
back over here real quick and play
around with this if we want if we wanted
to change this to jit danger for
instance then if we save this and run it
we're gonna get red text right so that's
cool now there is another attribute you
could play around with when it comes to
labels in your boot style and you use
multiple attributes you just put a comma
in there and then do the over the other
one you want so we can also do something
called inverse
and this will just sort of reverse
whatever your color is and give you sort
of a blocky looking background so if we
save this and run it's kind of
interesting
we see now the whole thing is like this
square of the inverse color so the text
was red now the block is red and the the
actual text color is white itself so
that's kind of cool keep that in mind if
you want to do something like that and
when it comes to labels that's pretty
much all there is to it so you could
inverse or not and then you pick your
color so okay that's cool now let's
create a button let's call this one
minor scroll button
and this is going to be a TB dot button
and just like the label pretty much
everything about this thing will act the
same way a regular kincher button acts
except you have this boot style
attribute all the TB widgets have a boot
style attribute that's sort of the main
difference so here we could set the text
we can set this equal to click me right
whatever and then we want to add a boot
style and set that equal equal to First
what color do we want this to be well
let's go primary this time and see how
that looks so let's get my underscore
button yeah pack
give this a pad y of 20 push down screen
a little bit let's save this in run see
how this looks and so you get this
primary color blue click me you'll
notice when you click on it there's
little dashes around it that's kind of
neat all right there we go so
there are several different attributes
you can play around with in the boot
style for your button so here we have
primary
let me just put this on another line
here so we can see we can change this
from a regular button to an outline so
this is kind of cool and let's change
this from primary to info
success let's see what success looks
like
I always wanted to know what success
looks like and you see now it's outlined
right that's what that outline attribute
does and of course the color is green if
we hover over it it turns back into a
blocky thing when you click it you get
the little white dashes so that's kind
of cool you can also sort of make it not
really even a button at all you can make
it just like a look like a link right so
instead of outline we could put just
link here save this and run it
now you're just going to get flat out
text but if you hover over it it kind of
changes color like an HTML link and
again you can click it like normal so
that's kind of cool I'm going to go
ahead and change that back to outline
very cool now buttons do things and to
do things with a button in kinter you
give it a command and the same thing
works with ttk bootstrap you give it a
command so let's create a command called
changer
we don't have that just yet so let's
come up here and create it
let's define changer
and here outside of here let's create a
counter and set it equal to zero just
for fun
and then let's set our counter plus
equal to one every time we click the
button and let's run some logic let's
say if counter modulus 2 equals zero
that means it's divisible by two that
means it's even let's change our label
underscore label dot config and set the
text equal to hello world just go ahead
and copy this else
let's set the text equal to Goodbye
World so if it's even it'll say hello
world if it's odd it'll say goodbye
world right so the main thing I want to
show you here is this dot config use dot
config in kinter to change things on the
Fly later on in your app and that same
thing holds true in ttk bootstrap so if
you're worried about that same exact
thing there so nothing to worry about
there we can go ahead and save this and
run it one last time we can click me uh
oh we need to make our label Global so
let's come up here and say Global
counter
there we go
now we come back here and run this guy
quick this Goodbye World hello we're all
goodbye World hello world so there you
have a very basic app with ttk bootstrap
like I said it's very similar to using
regular Canter or ttk widgets just a
couple little things really the boot
style thing is the main difference
you're going to deal with on a
day-to-day basis when you're using this
and uh pretty cool
in this video we want to look at check
boxes and there are lots of different
options for check boxes with ttk
bootstrap you have your regular check
box that you normally have you got a
little check box there you also have
these tool buttons where if you click on
it it sort of unhighlights or if you
click on it again it highlights and you
have the same thing with outlined there
you go and we also have these round
toggle buttons and square toggle buttons
so we're gonna look at all of these in
this video very cool and uh really easy
to use so I've got our basic kinter
starter code I'm calling it check
buttons.pi and I've got our theme set to
superhero and I've imported gtk
bootstrap as TB and first thing let's
just create a simple label so let's go
Miner score label and I'm just going to
use a regular kinter label for this and
let's just say uh click the check box or
check button whatever below and you know
just for fun let's give this a font of
helvetica and like a size of 18 and then
that's my underscore label dot pack this
guy and I'm gonna give it a pad y of
let's bring it down 40 from the top and
then 10 from the thing below it okay
so first things first let's create a
check button and remember from regular
cancer whenever we create a check button
check box it's called a check button in
kinter we create a variable and I'm
going to call this var1 and I'm going to
set that equal to an INT VAR and an end
VAR is akinter variable right it's an
integer variable and the reason why we
want integers because when you click a
check box we want it to be either a one
or a zero so if it's checked it'll be a
one if it's not checked it's a zero that
allows us to run logic very easily to
say hey if it's one do this if it's not
one do something else right so we'll set
up an invar for that and then I'm going
to create a check box I'm just going to
call it my check whatever and this is
going to be a TB dot check button
all right and so let's give this a boot
style of I'll say primary remember those
are our colors right primary secondary
info success danger all that stuff right
so that's really all we have to do there
and let's set the text equal to uh check
me out check button check
and then let's set the variable to that
var1 we just created and then we want to
give this
actually let's put start to put these on
separate lines because it's getting a
little hard to read
so our variable is going to be var1 we
want to set the on value so what is it
when it gets checked we'll set that to
one
we want to set the off value to zero so
if it's not checked give it a zero and
then let's give this a command of and
I'm going to call this Checker and what
this does is it'll run a function called
Checker every time we click the button
right so okay we'll create that in just
a second for now let's go my underscore
check dot pack and give this a pad y of
like I don't know 10 or so to push down
screen a bit so all right let's come up
here and Define our Checker function and
for now let's just pass so let's save
this and run just to make sure that's
working okay so let's head over to our
terminal I'm in my ctkinter.com
directory and let's run python check
buttons dot pi and when we do we get
this little thing here
says check me out there's a little box
we can click it it's blue or not all
right and if we want to change the color
remember we know how to do that we just
come up here to our boot style and let's
say we want to turn it green that would
be info if you're not familiar with the
colors take a look at the documentation
or check the previous video in this
playlist where I talked about all the
colors so we can come back over here
real quick just run this guy again and
now when we click on this it's that
light blue that's what info is we could
say danger for instance save this and
run it right now it's red so okay that
looks good so let's change this back to
primary I like primary
and if we want to play with this
function we don't necessarily have to
but if you're not familiar with how to
do check buttons in kinter just very
quickly we can say hey if var1 dot get
that will get whether it's a one or a
zero if it equals one then we can say I
don't know my underscore label dot
config
and set the text equal to checked
right else
we can set this equal to
unchecked right so save this and run it
now when we click this we check hey it's
checked when we uncheck it it's
unchecked right so a very simple example
but in this function here
you could do anything you want so we're
just changing the label obviously you
would do something else whatever you
want to do you do it in this function so
okay that's the check button very very
easy to use but there's also something
called a tool button which is a square
box it looks like a button but you can
toggle it on and off and it changes
color from the color to a muted version
of that color or gray if you uncheck it
so two buttons are really easy again I'm
going to go VAR 2 equals int VAR
because we always want to use it an INT
VAR with these guys and let's just call
this my underscore check two and this is
going to be a TB dot check button
again right but the boot style will now
change a little bit so first what color
do we want this well let's say we want
danger which is red so to change it from
a check button to a tool button all we
have to do is type in tool button
right these all can stay the same if we
want so I'll just kind of copy these to
make this quicker
instead of R1 it's obviously going to be
var2 but everything else will stay the
same now we can my underscore check to
dot pack and give this a pad y of like I
don't know 10 or something push it down
screen a little bit uh that looks good
except oh we forgot text so here let's
say text equals
tool button all right
give this a comma okay let's go ahead
and save this run it
see how this looks all right now we got
this tool button you'll notice if we
hover over it it changes color that's
kind of cool right if we click it boom
now this is checked and uh it stays red
now we can click it again and move our
Mouse away and now it becomes unchecked
again and it still changes color when we
hover very cool so that's the tool
button you can also do a tool button
with an outline instead of this solid
color right super easy to do that in
fact I'm just going to copy this whole
thing and
come here and say outlined tool button
and just paste all this in here and
let's change this to
var3 my check three
set that to three
and instead of saying tool button let's
say outlined tool button
and here same thing we have this we have
tool button but we also then pass in a
third thing called outline
and that's all there is to it now we can
oh we gotta change this to my check
three okay save this head back over here
run this guy now we get this cool
outline button same thing if we hover
over it it changes color if we click it
it becomes solid if we unclick it it
goes back to outline and uh very cool
okay next we want to look at round
toggle buttons a little bit fancier but
uh pretty cool I'm just going to go
ahead and copy all of this stuff and
paste it in here and let's change this
to var4 my check for
it's this Devar for and come down here
and change that to var4
but now let's change this boot style
from danger color let's mix it up let's
change it to success I think that's
green and instead of a tool button
and outline
we want a round Dash toggle and here
let's call this for the text round
toggle all right and yeah that's all
there is to that let's go ahead and save
this
head back over here run this guy again
and now we have this cool round toggle
button if we click it it changes to
Green because success is green very cool
and you'll notice it's not changing here
because we didn't dial in the function
for this but uh
very cool again this is green because
over here we called success if you
wanted to color it different color you
just change the color of that so very
cool finally we have the square toggle
button and it is very much like the
round toggle button let's just change
this to five call this my check five bar
five
and my check five and here let's call
this Square toggle button and you will
never guess how to do this we change
this from round to square
very difficult and let's get crazy here
let's change this to warning I think
that's yellow or orange or something
like that so yeah that's all we have to
do that's the only difference there
save this run it
now we have this cool Square toggle boom
we click this
changes to
what is that orange I guess
very cool
so those are check boxes tool buttons
outline tool buttons round toggles and
square toggles with ttk bootstrap very
easy to do all of these things and much
much nicer looking than the regular
kinter check button that you're probably
used to but works pretty much the same
as the kinter check button
all right like I said in this video I
want to talk about resizing buttons not
just the size of the button but also the
font on the button you can see here's a
regular button here's a bigger button
now this is a little tricky and that's
why we need to talk about it so we've
got our basic starter code I'm calling
this button underscore size.5 because
why not and we're importing ttk
bootstrap as TB this has to be installed
so you have to pip install it if you
haven't and I've set the window to
superhero and it's 500 by 350. so let's
start out by creating a button and I'm
just going to call this my underscore
button and this is going to be a TV DOT
button because we've imported dtk
bootstrap as TB and I want to set the
text as I don't know hello world now
normally to change the size of a button
we would give this a font we would go
font equal and I'd say like helvetica
and then I maybe make it size 18 and
that would make the whole button bigger
to compensate for the size of that font
but if we try this my underscore button
dot pack let's give this a pad why like
40 push it down screen save this head
over to our terminal I'm in my
ctcinter.com directory and let's run
python
button underscore size.5 and we get an
error right unknown option font and it
doesn't even know what that is so we
obviously can't do that now we can get
rid of that and with regular kinter we
can change the size so we can set the
width to like uh 30. if we save this and
run it
you see we get this longer button now
this is I believe in font right so it's
font characters 30 font characters this
is not pixel so if you have a bigger
font
it'll be bigger characters and the
button will be a different size which is
kind of weird now uh this might be what
you're looking for if you just want to
change the size and not the font you can
use with you cannot use height there is
no height attribute so we can try and
change this to 20. if we do we're going
to get an error again and it doesn't
know what height is right so
what can we do well first off let's just
get rid of this hyphen width I want to
change the font almost always when I
want to make a button bigger is because
I want the font bigger on the on the
button so how do we do that well we have
to use a style right and this is also a
little bit tricky now I have a video on
Style with Kinder I'll link to it up
there you can check that out if you're
not familiar with style this is a
slightly different use of style and I'll
show you why in just a second so first
of all let's change our boot style
and let's make this uh success which I
think is green let's save this around
just to make sure yeah so we've got a
green button and we want to make it
bigger so how do we do that well like I
said we have to use a style so I'm going
to call you can call it anything you
want I'm going to call it minor score
style and this is a TB dot style widget
okay so there's our style now we need to
configure it so let's go my underscore
style dot configure and inside here
first we have to name it so I usually
call these my DOT t button
now whatever widget you're doing it's
going to be T the widget so t button T
label T check button Etc like I said I
got a video on this you can check it out
if you're not familiar with all this
style stuff so there we go my t button
and then we can do whatever we want so
let's give this guy a font and I want to
say hell
vedica
and then size 18. then down here in our
button we have to say hey use that style
so we'll set style equal to
and let's put these on another line
because it's starting to get a little
bit hard to read and we just set that
equal to my
dot t button which is what we called it
right here so you would think this would
work and it sort of does but sort of not
so let's take a look at this
sure enough our button is bigger our
font is bigger but wait a second this is
a primary color
what's going on here remember we set
this as success not primary what's going
on well it's overriding the uh I don't
know subclass maybe
that sound right I don't know it's doing
something right that we don't want and
it's because we called this my that's
sort of what I would normally do but
instead of that you need to name it what
color system thing you're using right so
we're using success so we need to call
this success.t button and then down here
when we reference it it's success dot t
button now if we save this guy head back
over here run it again we get our
success right well that's cool and that
works but what if you want to use
something besides the primary secondary
success info color scheme if you head
back over to our documentation you
remember there's all kinds of things you
can use you could use outline you can
use Link well I guess that's the only
two things you could use outline and
Link how do we use those well super easy
we just add them here with another dot
so if we want this to be success and
outline we just type in outline now
notice this is capitalized if you do
lowercase won't work right it has to be
capitalized that's the convention here
so the name of your color that you want
to use success and then whatever you
want to do with it right and then we can
come down here and again call success
dot outline
okay now if we save this guy head back
over here run it again
we get our success outline button it's
now bigger and that works great now we
can also give this more width right so
we can come back over here and like we
did earlier we could you know set the
width
equal to 20 or something come back run
this guy again
and now we have a wider Button as well
that's it and that's all there is to it
so a little complicated a little bit
tricky but once you understand the
tricks here and those are mainly just
in the naming convention
right there it's a piece of cake
okay so in this video we want to look at
using combo boxes with ttk bootstrap and
you can see we can click on this and
I've got it set up two ways one where if
we select the thing we can click the
button and it will update the label the
other way we can just use a binding and
say click on Wednesday boom it says you
picked Wednesday so we're gonna look at
all of this stuff in this video so I've
got a file I'm just calling it combo dot
Pi it's a regular starter code that we
always have we've imported ttk bootstrap
stb I set the theme name to superhero
and we're ready to go so let's create a
label I'm going to call it my label and
it's going to be a tb.label and remember
we're importing it as TB that's why this
is TB dot whatever and we want to put
this in root and I want the text to say
just for now hello world and let's give
this a font of helvetica with a size 18.
so okay that's good let's underscore
label dot pack this guy and let's give
this a pad y of say 30 to really push it
down the screen
okay so now let's
create drop down options
and I'm just going to create a variable
called days and this is going to be a
python list and so we can go Monday
Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday
this is very exciting Friday
Saturday
we should probably capitalize Saturday
it's the most important day and Sunday
so we've got this python list and we're
going to use that to insert into our
combo box to have the options that drop
down whenever we click on the combo box
right basic combo box stuff so now let's
create combo box and up here let's say
create label
we don't want the label to be jealous
that it didn't get its own comment right
so let's go my combo call this anything
you want and this is going to be a TV
DOT combo box and we want to put it in a
root and let's give this a boot style of
say success to make it green and if
you're not familiar with this color
system check back the previous videos in
this series I go over all that in great
detail so we want to also set the values
to days and that's just this list we
created right there and really that's
all we need so let's now my underscore
combo dot pack this guy and let's give
this a pad y of 20. now let's go ahead
and save this and run it just to make
sure this is looking okay so I'm in my
cetekinter.com directory and let's just
go Python combo.pi and when we do we see
this drop down list it says it has all
these listed when we click on them
nothing happens and you'll notice by
default it's blank so we can set that to
anyone we want by default so let's go
ahead and do that let's say set combo
default and we do that the same way we
do it as in regular kinter we just call
my combo Dot current
and we pass in the number of the thing
we want to show up so python lists
always start at zero so if we want
Monday it's zero if we want Tuesday it
would be one right so we could set that
to zero let's go ahead and save this and
run it just to make sure that's looking
okay and sure enough now it says Monday
there instead of it being blank and you
notice that it's green that's the
success color we can change that by
changing it to primary or danger or info
or any of the other the default whatever
you want for your color so okay that's
good so now let's create a button to
where when we select one of these and
click the button something happens this
text up here changes super easy to do
that let's
create a button and I'm just going to
call it my underscore button and this is
going to be a TV DOT button
you want to put it in root we want the
text to say click me whatever let's give
this a command of clicker and let's give
this a boot style
of
I don't know danger we'll make it red
right so then let's my underscore button
dot pack this guy and give him a pad y
of 20. okay so now we've got this
clicker command
and we need to create it so that when we
click that button something happens so
let's come up here to the top
and let's define Clicker and what do we
want to do we just want to change our
label so let's go my underscore label
dot config and let's just change the
text and I'm going to create an F string
and say you clicked on
and then we can pass in
my underscore combo
dot get and that will get whatever we
have selected so let's put our
exclamation mark on there and okay we
should be good to go let's go ahead and
save this and run it see if that worked
so we can click on Friday you clicked on
Friday and that's all there is to it
super simple now we can also bind this
thing so when we so that we don't need a
button at all we could just click on
here say we click Wednesday the text
will change to you clicked on Wednesday
right so how do we do that well same way
we do it with regular
enter let's come down here and let's
bind the combo box so once we do this
the button will be pretty much
irrelevant we won't need to click it
anymore but I'll just leave the button
there for now so let's go my underscore
combo dot bind and then inside of here
this is always the format you have an
action and then a command of some sort
and let's say click underscore bind or
something like that
and this is the function that will get
called whenever we click the combo box
and inside of here we just use two sets
of these angular brackets and we pass in
combo
box selected
right and the C is capitalized and the S
is capitalized the b in box is NOT
capitalized and I see people make that
mistake all the time so make sure that's
lowercase so combo box selected
and this function will get called now we
don't have this function yet so we need
to come up here and create it
and let's create binding function and so
let's define our click bind now this is
a binding and with all bindings we need
to pass an event because a click is an
event and that needs to get passed to
the function now we're not actually
going to use that for anything but it
still needs to get passed because the
binding will send that extra info and if
the function doesn't see it you're gonna
have problems so now we can just copy
this whole thing and paste that in there
and let's give this guy a comment too
create
I don't know button click function
good enough okay so that should do the
trick let's save this and head back over
here run this one more time
so now when we click on here and let's
pick Saturday hey you clicked on
Saturday if we click Wednesday you
clicked on Wednesday and if we click
this again nothing happens because it
still says Wednesday and that function
will get called and it'll just say you
clicked on Wednesday which is what it
already said so it doesn't look like
it's changing But whichever way you want
to do binding or using a button super
easy with ttk bootstrap and it's all
there is to it
in this video we're going to look at the
entry box for ttk bootstrap now this is
super useful because you're always going
to use entry boxes and there are a few
different little things you need to know
about it so we're going to dive into it
in this video so I've got our basic
starter code that we've always got I'm
calling it entry underscore widget.pi
and we've imported ttk bootstrap you've
got a pimp install that if you haven't
yet and then we've set the superhero
theme and that's pretty much it so let's
come down here and create an entry
widget so I'm going to go my underscore
entry and that's going to be a TB dot
entry widget
and the reason why it's TB is because
I'm importing ttk bootstrap as TB up
here and we want to put this thing in
root and that'll be fine for now so
let's go my underscore entry dot pack
and let's give this a pad why of like 50
to really push it down the screen so now
I want to create a button to where
whenever I type something in the entry
box and click the button it does
something it does something with that
text so let's just call this my
underscore button and this is going to
be a TV DOT button you want to put it in
root and let's give this a boot style of
like I don't know danger or something
make it a red button I don't know and
maybe outline as well just for fun we
want the text to say click me I don't
know
and we want the command to equal I don't
know let's just say speak something like
that now we'll create this function in
just a second so let's go minerscore
button dot pack and give this a pad y of
20 to push down screen finally let's
create a quick label let's go minerscore
label and this is going to be a tv.label
I want to put it in root I want the text
to say I don't know hello world for now
or even just nothing at all
yeah let's leave it nothing at all so
let's go my underscore label dot pack
and give this a bad y of 20 push down
screen a little bit okay so now when we
click that button we want this speak
function to run and let's just take that
my underscore label and then dot config
it and set the text equal to an F string
and let's say you typed
and then we put in Brackets and then we
can call my entry whatever we typed into
my entry so let's go my entry dot get
and just put that up on the screen so
let's go ahead and save this and run it
see what this looks like head over to
our terminal I'm in my C T kinter.com
directory and let's run python entry
widget dot pi and when we do we get this
basic entry box we could say John elder
or something like that here we see click
me we click it it says you typed John
Elder very simple so here's your basic
entry box now we didn't do any styling
to this we didn't change anything about
it this is just the sort of default view
right so that's fine maybe that's what
you want but we can play around with
this so let's do that let's head back
over here and the first thing we could
do obviously is let's get this a boot
style as you do with all dtk bootstrap
things and then we can add a color
scheme here so your basic color schemes
are primary secondary success info
warning danger light and dark so that's
for basically all widgets in ttk
bootstrap we understand that we've
looked at this before so let's say I
want green that's success we could do
that save this run it again and we
misspelled boot style
[Laughter]
so let's go boot dial there we go
now if we save this and run it again we
get the box outlined in green green is
success
pretty cool what if we want to change
the size of this thing well we do that
the same way we would with a regular
Kinder entry widget we just set the font
equal to and let's say I want to change
the text to helvetica and let's say we
want the size 18 that will make 18 size
text which will definitionally make the
Box correspondingly big to 18 size text
so that's one way we can do it save that
and run it
now we've got a bigger box right
you typed hello now this text is uh sort
of light colored light like gray
something like that whatever the color
that is we can change that as well let's
start to add these on separate lines so
we can read this easier and to do that
normally with a kinter entry widget you
would set the foreground to whatever
color but with this we need to set the
four
round you need to spell it out so we can
use any sort of HTML color code so zero
zero three six six zero something like
that
or we could just you know say red or
green we want it to be the same color so
hey there whatever now it's green right
hey you typed hey there very cool that's
one way to do it we can also set the
width attribute so if we come back here
and instead set the width to let's say
five now this is characters it's not
pixels so our text is size 18 so that's
18 sized characters so keep that in mind
so it's not a great way to do it but you
know
that's conturso you can see now it's
much smaller I could go on two three
four five that's five characters six so
it's exactly five characters in width so
you go like that if you want I don't
know kind of weird I just like changing
the font text finally we can make this
into like a password protected deal uh
let me change this to 15 and we do that
using show so we could say hey show
these characters whenever somebody types
and we could put a little asterisk or
whatever so we can run this guy again
now when we type we get nothing but
Stars when we click it the actual text
still comes through it doesn't come
through as stars it comes through as
whatever you text so I I typed in John
Elder here and click this it says you
type John Elder this is just for like
appearance sake right so that's cool we
did stars but you know you could do
anything you want I could put you know
ampersands or whatever whatever you want
this will show
now we get a bunch of ampersands I'm
gonna go ahead and change that back
because that's just plain weird so
that's the entry widget for ttk
bootstrap super simple acts almost
exactly as you would expect it to just
like a regular entry box and uh yeah
pretty cool
in this video we're going to look at
this flood gauge very cool we can start
it we can stop it we can increment it by
a few when we do we can get the correct
position it's at 67. and this is
something new and different that just
comes with ttk bootstrap obviously
there's no flood gauge in regular kinter
so this is kind of exciting and really
fun so we're going to dive into that in
this video so I've got a file here I'm
just calling it flood.pi it's our basic
ttk bootstrap starter code that we
always have we imported ttk bootstrap
stb you got to pimp install that if you
haven't already we've set the window
theme to superhero and pretty much
everything else is normal Kinder so
let's come down here and create a flood
gauge and I'm just going to call this my
gauge call it anything you want and
that's going to be a TB dot lud gauge
and it's TB dot because we've imported
ttk bootstrap as TB up here so TB goes
there and we want to put this in root
and we want to give it a boot style and
you're going to use any of your
bootstrap color styles I'm going to pick
success that's green I believe you could
pick primer very secondary danger info a
light dark all the regular colors that
you have to choose from now we can also
set the font for this so I'm going to
make the font a little bigger just so
it's easier for us to see I'm going to
set that as helvetica and give it like a
size 18. now here's where it gets a
little bit different so right off the
bat I want to give this a mask of POS
short for position right now we can keep
track of the exact position of our flood
Gauge by passing in just like if it was
an F string you know you kind of do an F
string like that it's not an F string
but we put then a percentage sign after
it this will automatically update with
the current position as it moves up and
down right so you don't have to do that
but if you want it to sort of keep track
of what it's doing on the flood gauge
itself that's very very useful so we
could do all kinds of different things
we can set the maximum for instance so
you know you might want this to be a
hundred or you might want it to be 50 or
you know whatever you want I'm just
going to put it 80 for now just for fun
we'll play around with this and then you
could also set the Orient and by default
this is going to be horizontal there you
go so if you're going to do horizontal
which is left to right you don't have to
put your Orient in there you could just
leave that out but if you want to do it
up and down then it would be vertical
and we'll play around with this and
change it up in a bit so finally we can
set the value that we want to start on
so you might want to start it at zero
obviously you could just leave this one
off if that's the case but if you want
to start at a certain level you could
put it right there so now let's
underscore gauge dot pack this guy and
let's give this a pad why like 50. there
you go so let's go ahead and save this
head back over to our code and run this
guy I'm in my cetkinter.com directory
and let's run Python flood.pi and when
we do we see pos position of 10 percent
it's sort of 10 up and there we go so
okay that's cool now this is kind of
small we can make it a lot bigger if we
want and we do that by playing the pack
value so we could go
fill equals x that's X left and right
and I suppose we should capitalize it
but not sure that matters so okay let's
save this and run it and now you're
going to see this is massively all the
way it fills all the way left to right
so okay that's you know kind of not
great so we can also give this a pad X
of like I don't know 20 to give it
padding on each side make it a little
bit nicer to look at I suppose okay so
there we go so I kind of like that we'll
just leave it like that so all right now
let's create a button that we could
start it and stop it and add some
incrementation and also I'm going to
change this from 10 back down to zero
because I don't know I don't really need
to start it at ten percent so there you
go so let's create a start underscore
button and that's going to be a TB dot
button we want to put it in root we want
the text to say start and let's give
this a boot style of like danger and
outline so it'll be like red outlined
and let's give this a command of starter
and we haven't created that yet but we
will in a second so let's start unscrew
button dot pack and give this pad wide
like 20 push down screen a little bit
now I'm just going to copy this a couple
of times
and this one we'll call a stop button
and we'll have the text say stop
and we'll give it a command of stopper I
don't know and then this one will be uh
we'll call this Inc for increment
Inc and this will be increment
and here let's call this anchor I don't
know or incrementer there we go so now
we want to create these three functions
starter stopper and incrementer so let's
come up here
and let's define starter
and we want to pass and let's define
stopper
incrementer
and we want to pass so okay to start
it's very easy so let's start the gauge
we just call my underscore gauge dot
start
that's it now to stop it same thing we
call my underscore gauge dot stop very
complicated and to increment it we just
call my underscore gauge dot step and
then we say what steps do we want so I
want it to go every 10 right so when we
click the button it pops up 10 and then
it stops so we can go ahead and save
this and let's run this and it should
work out okay let's see what we got
so here we have start stop and increment
so let's start and you can see it just
one at a time
goes like that we could stop it by
stopping and now we can increment so 52
62 72 and then once it gets to the top
it just starts on over again right so
that's kind of cool
and there we go now one thing I'll
mention is how it comes to the end and
then it starts over at zero that's
because of the mode so you can change
that if you want when you define the
flood gauge so here we can set the mode
to and the default is determinate
right that means keep on going basically
but we can change it to indeterminate if
we want if we save this and run it
you'll see this sort of uh ping pongs
back and forth from
start to finish so we go start and you
can see one it looks different the gauge
itself is not full but when it hits the
end boom it pops back down and it keeps
going and it keeps counting so we're at
now 180 100 200
240 and it's going up to 80 which is
what we set our value our max value at
so this is kind of weird you may want
that for some reason same thing works
with increment it will Bop back and
forth as you increment it so just sort
of keep that in mind I'm going to change
it back to determinant because
indeterminate it's just you know
freaking me out so let's come down here
and let's create a label now so
my label this is going to be a TV DOT
label we want to put it in root and we
want the text to say
I don't know position something like
that
and now it's my underscore label dot
pack give this a pad live 20 push it
down screen a little bit so with this
label we want to update it every time we
hit the increment button to show us
exactly what position we have and you
can use this to get the position of
anything even when it's in starting and
stopping but we're just going to do
increment one because that's easiest so
we can come up here and go minor score
label dot config
and set the text equal to and I'm going
to create an F string and go position
and then pass in
this is going to be my underscore gauge
dot variable
dot get
so that will get the current position
that's that variable and this gets
created automatically with the with the
widget and it keeps track of that
automatically so you can at any time see
where your position is in your flood
Gauge by calling the name of your gauge
dot variable and then dot gets or like
an entry box dot get it right so let's
go back over here try this guy again
we're at position zero let's increment
at one and it says boom 10 20 30 40 50
60 70 and when it hits 80 boom it starts
over at zero and again we can start and
stop here and now it's 34 if we click it
again boom 44 so any position it
currently is at it will keep track of
that so very cool and very interesting
now just to make sure here we can come
back over here and make sure that this
is a number it's supposed to be a
floating Point number but let's see if
we can add 10 to it just to make sure so
if we increment it boom now it goes to
20 because it's 10 plus 10 right so 30.
40 and we're good to go so it's
definitely a number you could do numbery
things with it you don't have to convert
it from a string like sometimes you have
to do with things and that's very cool
so I'm gonna get rid of that
so that's the plug gauge pretty cool fun
little widget and I'm really happy to
see these little extra things popping up
in in ttk bootstrap and makes it a lot
of fun to use and all kinds of cool
things you can do with this and that's
all there is to it
in this video we're going to look at
this calendar widget for dtk
bootstrapping technically it's called
the date entry widget and I'm going to
show you how to use it how to get
information from it some interesting
things you can do with it and should be
a lot of fun all right so I've got a
file I'm just calling it dater.pi and
it's our basic ttk bootstrap starter
code that we always have so we're
importing ttk bootstrap as TB not as ttk
but stb because that's the way I like to
do it and pretty much everything is the
same as regular Canter let's come down
here and create a date entry widget so
I'm going to call this my date and this
is going to be ATB dot date entry widget
we want to put it in root and just like
everything else in ptk bootstrap you can
give this a boot style and pick any
color you want so you know primary
secondary danger info light dark all the
basic colors that come with ttk
bootstrap if you're not familiar with
those colors check the previous videos
in the series and learn all about that
so I'm just going to do Danger let's do
red all right and for now let's just
leave it at that so let's go my
underscore date dot pack and give this a
pad y of like 50 to really push it down
the screen so if we save this and run it
head over to our CTC kinter.com
directory and around python data dot Pi
we get this widget and it's red because
we set the boot style to danger and we
click on it it's got red here and we can
click on a certain thing and when we do
it updates in this box here so if we
click on the 13th it updates to the 13th
and that's cool so one thing to keep in
mind is this is basically an entry box
so when we want to get whatever's in
here we have to get the entry box for
this widget I'll show you how to do that
in just a second but this is basically
it so this is cool
and we can play around with different
settings in this you know what the
default start date is and things like
that so let's go ahead and look at that
but first let's say somebody clicks on
February 14th now it says 214 23 here
how do we programmatically get that and
do something with it in our program
right well super easy let's come back
over to our code and I'm going to create
a button I'm going to call this my
underscore button and it's going to be a
TB dot button
you want to put it in a root we want the
text to say get date something like that
we can give this a boot style of
let's say danger and outline so it's red
but outlined
and let's give this a command of I don't
know 80. something like that whatever so
we don't have this function we'll go
ahead and create it but first let's my
underscore button dot pack this guy give
this pad y of 20 push down screen a
little bit
finally let's create a label so my
underscore label and this is going to be
a TB dot label
you want to put it in a root we want the
text to be nothing for now and let's
minor Square label
dot pack this guy and give it a pad of Y
of 20 push down screen now maybe we do
want to put something here so let's say
you picked something right so okay we've
got these things now let's come up here
and create that function so we want to
Define dati all right so let's say we
want to grab whatever the person
selected as the date and update this
label with that information how do we do
that well we can grab the date and to do
that let's go minerscore label dot
config
and let's set the text equal to now I'm
going to create an F string and I'm
going to say you picked
and then we want to pass in something
into this label
and what do we want to pass in well
remember we called our calendar my date
so that would be my date dot entry dot
get and this is just the dot get that
you would use for any entry box in
kinter right we're just getting
whatever's in there so let's go ahead
and save this and run it make sure that
worked and back over here run this guy
so let's say we select again 14th
Valentine's Day it's my birthday coming
up all right we click get date and it
says you picked 214 2023 now what
exactly is this returning is this
returning a date a date time object what
well actually this is just returning a
string so you can't do date time stuff
to it unless you convert it into a date
time object which we can do that if you
want but just keep in mind this is not
an integer it's not a float it's it's
just a string of text right so okay
that's cool now let's configure this
thing a little bit so by default it just
opens up to whatever date the day is so
today is the 31st of January so if we
you know run this guy again we could see
it just says 131.23 that's just today's
date so if you want to set a specific
date either when it opens or
programmatically or whatever you could
do that and to do that let's head back
over to our code and when you define
your widget right here we can set the
start date we can set that equal to
something now this is actually a date
time object this is not a string so in
order to use date time stuff we need to
import date from python so let's come up
here and go from date time we want to
import date so now we can create date
objects and we can use them so here we
just want to call the date function
create a little date object thing and
here we can set the date to whatever we
want now the format is going to be year
so 2023 let's say we want the month of
two which is February and we want the
day of 14. so if we save this and run it
we see by default now it shows up as
214.23 if we click this at 214 23 is
selected now of course we can still
change it to say the ninth if we click
the date it says hey you picked the
ninth so that's cool so one other thing
I want to point out look at this it
starts on Sunday right Sunday is the
first one listed in this very first
column and it goes Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday Saturday we
can change that we can change with the
default start date so maybe your
calendar you want it to start on Monday
right that's not unusual so how do we
get Monday to be the First Column well
Sunday is technically the sixth day of
the week in Python so it starts at
Monday zero one two three four Saturday
is five Sunday is six so we could change
What's called the first week day to
change that First Column so just up here
in our quote our code here where we
Define our widget I'm just going to set
the first week day to zero so remember
Monday is zero it's sort of like a
python list right they start at zero and
so in the world of python Monday is zero
or at least for this widget right so if
we want Monday that's Zero by default
this is going to be six which is Sunday
but we want Monday so just change it to
zero so we save this head back over here
and run it and we click this now we see
Monday as the First Column listed and
Sunday's way over here so okay that's
cool nice that you can change that very
quickly and automatically
all right so that's basically pretty
much all you can do with this which is
very cool already but let's say you want
to instead of having a thing pop up like
this when you click on it maybe you want
a button that you can say hey pick the
date and you don't want this whole thing
on the screen but you still want the
functionality of this thing how do you
do that well we can do that too let's
head back over to our code so up here at
the top we can from ttk bootstrap
dot dialogues so this is basically a
dialog box we want to import query box
right so if we save this now let's come
down here and let's create a second
button let's call this minor score
button now actually let's just copy all
of this because that's going to be
easier so let's change this to my button
two and
here let's say get calendar Maybe
and instead of Danger let's call this I
don't know success just change the color
a little bit and let's just change the
command to thing because I'm being lazy
so now we can come up here and let's
define thing and let's just set some
variable I'm going to call it thing or
Cal let's call it cow short for calendar
and we could set that equal to just a
query box
right which is what we imported right
here so now let's update our label let's
go actually let's just grab this
and pop this out instead of my
date.entry DOT get this is going to be
Cal dot get underscore date because
up here we're getting that entry box
because this whole date entry widget has
sort of been
created for ttk bootstrap but
underlyingly it uses the date entry ttk
widget right and that thing to use it
and grab a date use this get date
function right so we're going to be
using that for this query box so we
would call get date right so okay that
works let's go ahead and save this and
run it see what this does so here we've
got this get calendar when we click it
boom up Pops our own brand new
independent of this thing over here
date entry calendar thing and you'll
notice the color is primary I'm sure you
could mess around with this change color
I didn't even try but you would probably
want to do that or just understand that
it's going to be primary one of the two
so now I'm going to click on January
12th when I click on that boom it
updates to 1 12 23 and so we get the
date there we can change it again to the
20th boom it updates to the 20th now we
can still use this guy up here and
February 10th
click get the date boom February 10th so
you know whichever of these two methods
you want to use if your program is more
suited to have this thing right here pop
up on the screen and you know just
always be present then use this right
totally fine if you don't want this
whole thing up on the screen all the
time and you just want to call a
calendar whenever you want to call a
calendar then use the second method hit
calendar boom up it pops do your thing
and you're good to go so that's the date
entry widget for ttk bootstrap very cool
super useful very very nice looking I
mean this thing looks great super useful
super functional and pretty easy to use
in this video we're going to look at
frames and labels with ttk bootstrap now
this may sound a little boring but
there's a couple cool things here that
you're going to want to know about so it
should be pretty cool so I've got a file
I'm just calling it framer.pi it's our
basic ttk bootstrap starter code that
we've always got got the theme name set
to superhero and let's come down here
and create a frame so I'm going to call
this Miner score frame and this is going
to be a TB dot frame because we're
importing ttk bootstrap as TB and we
just want to put this in root now we can
give this a boot style equal to all of
the other boot style options we've
looked at so you could change the color
to Danger primary secondary info success
light dark all those things so I'm just
going to start out with light
see how that goes so let's go minerscore
frame dot pack give this a pad y of like
40 or so really push it down the screen
so okay we've got this thing but there's
nothing in it so let's just put some
stuff in it so let's build a quick entry
form so I'm going to call this my entry
and this is going to be ATB dot entry
and we want to put this in my frame so
to put things in frames you just
reference them like that and let's give
this a font of helvetica
and size 18 just to make it bigger so
that it expands our frame a little bit
and let's go my underscore entry
that pack give this a pad y of like 20
and a pad X of 20 to push down screen
inside the frame
okay so let's also create a quick button
so let's go my underscore button and
this is going to be a TB dot button
we want to put it in my frame as well
I want the text to say click me all
right and we can give this a boot style
of anything we like so I'm just going to
give this a dark color
and let's give this a command of I don't
know thing or something like that we'll
create this function in just a second so
let's get my underscore button yeah pack
give this pad wife 20 and also a pad X
of 20. okay so I'm going to come up here
real quick and create that function
and for now we'll just pass okay last
but not least let's create a label so
this video is about frames and labels
and we've got labels in ttk bootstrap
we've already used them in past videos
but I'm going to talk about them a
little bit because there's something
cool about them that you're going to
want to know about so let's call this
minor Square label and this is going to
be a TB dot label and let's just put
this in root let's put it outside of the
frame and let's give this a text of
hello there something like that and it's
also give it a font of
helvetica
and a size 18 to make it nice and big
and then that's my underscore label
that pack this guy and give him a pad y
of 20. so let's just save this and see
what we've got so far so head over to
your terminal I'm in my ctkinter.com
directory and let's just run python
framer.pi and when we do we've got this
Frame this it's a light color frame
we've got a button that doesn't do
anything we've got an entry box that
doesn't do anything and we've got a
label that just has the default text
which is in this theme light colored so
okay that's pretty much what we would
expect now we can change the color of
the label we already know how to do that
we just come down here and let's give it
a boot style of anything we want we
could say success if we want make it
make it horribly green and ugly save
that run it and we've got now green
that's the success color right so okay
that's cool but we can also do something
else with these labels we can invert
them so that's really kind of cool so
let's come back over here so we could
just give this a boot style of inverse
so inverse so all right let's go ahead
and save that see how this looks and now
it's inverted it's got like a little
background around it right so that's
kind of cool right so it looks ugly like
that but in this instance to make it
look cooler I would probably give this a
light theme
like that save that and run it and now
it kind of matches that that's kind of
cool so this gives you a lot of
flexibility to make your app look a
certain way if you needed to and uh very
cool now we can also change the color of
the frame if we want
which you know you probably would want
to do that so instead of light let's
make it dark
whatever go ahead and save it run it and
you can see now it's dark that's kind of
cool right the button kind of disappears
so you would probably want to change the
color of your button change the boots
down there now you can use all of the
boot style colors for both of these
labels and Frames like I said so you
know info success danger primary
secondary uh what are the other ones
like dark there's a couple more you
check the prior videos in this series to
uh check those out if you're not
familiar with them yet but very cool now
one thing I want to mention a lot of
themes have background colors so you may
not be able to match the theme color to
the frame and there are times when you
just want a frame to be invisible and
you want to be able to do stuff in that
frame for instance like if we're packing
everything on the screen but we need to
grid certain things I would put them in
a frame because then you can Grid in a
frame right we've done this lots of
different times so if that was the case
you just wanted to make it invisible
what you could do is head over to your
code and instead of making making this a
TV frame just make it a regular
bootstrap frame right so then you just
have to get rid of the boot style
because regular T Contour frames don't
have a boot style so I'll just comment
that out if we save this head back over
to our terminal and run this now we've
got the frame but it's invisible
and we could do things like grid inside
of it or whatever you want so keep in
mind even if you may be using the dtk
bootstrap Library you can still use the
stuff from old kinter if you want or ttk
if you want to you just have to import
it like normal so very cool those are
frames and those are labels that's
pretty much all there is to frames and
labels it's not that exciting I get it
but very useful you know something
you're going to use in every app that
you ever make so I thought I'd talk
about it
in this video we're going to look at the
menu button and these are the menu
buttons so uh we've got you know I've
got this danger colored one and we can
change the color I click primary it
changes the primary secondary danger
info we can do outlines that looks
pretty cool outline secondary ooh
outline danger and you can see the
little text updates every time I click
something so that's what we're going to
look at in this video so I've got some
starter codes we've always got them
calling it menu underscore button dot pi
and we're using the superhero theme for
ttk bootstrap we've imported the library
right there and here we go so how do we
build these things well they're a little
complicated but not too bad so I'm just
going to create a variable I'm going to
call it my underscore menu and this is
going to be a TV DOT menu button and
it's TB because I've imported dtk
bootstrip as TB
and we want to put this guy in root
let's give it a boot style of like
warning I think that's orange maybe I
don't know whatever and then let's give
it some text and let's just have it say
things I don't know this is the text
that's going to appear before you click
on anything so before it's opened or
clicked on that's the text it'll show up
so things all right whatever so then
that's my underscore menu
dot pack and let's give this a pad y of
like 20 really push it down screen so
let's save this and run it just to see
if that worked should have so let's head
over to our terminal I'm in
myctkinter.com directory and let's run
python menu underscore button and when
we do we get things when we click on it
nothing happens because we haven't told
it to do anything yet so okay that looks
good head back over here and I'm gonna
push this down a little bit give it a 50
instead of 20. Okay so we've got this
guy but now there's nothing inside of it
now to put things inside of our menu
button we need to create basically a
little menu inside of our menu button so
let's create
basic menu and call this anything you
want but I'm going to call it inside
underscore menu because you know if we
called it menu is it the menu button is
it the menu It's Complicated so I'm just
going to call it inside menu because
it's inside of our menu button but you
know call it anything you want so this
is going to be a TB dot menu and then we
need to pass in my underscore menu which
is just what we named our menu button up
here right this whole thing so okay that
looks good now we can add items to our
inside menu right so first
these are supposed to have variables
assigned to them I don't use the
variable because I just find you don't
need to we have to add a label we can
use the label as the variable but if you
need to use a variable you call the same
thing you want I'm going to call it item
underscore variable
because you know it's an item we're
adding to the menu and then we just give
this a string VAR right this is just
akinter string VAR variable thing right
you're probably familiar with those so
now we need to create a list of items
that we want to put in our menu and then
sort of loop through that list and add
them to our menu so let's do that with
for Loops let's go for X call it
anything you want in and now let's just
create our python list of things we want
so I want to put different colors in
there different boot Styles so when we
click on it we can change it so we'll
start out with adding primary we could
do secondary like that
we can do danger that's the red color we
could do info you can also change these
to be outline instead of solid so let's
go outline primary and outline secondary
and just do a few of these because it's
pretty boring the outline uh what say
danger Maybe
and what outline info
I think that's good enough so we need a
colon at the end of this because We're
looping right this is a for Loop
there we go now what are we doing as we
Loop well we're adding
things to our inside
underscore menu and what are we doing
we're adding actually a radio button all
right you can add a check button but
that gets a little goofy we want a radio
button because we only want to select
one thing at a time so all right add a
radio button and then we're giving them
a label of X which is what each of these
will are right and now if you want to
give the variable you can add the
variable of our item underscore VAR I
never really use that but if you wanted
to you could and that would be how you
do it so okay that looks good so the
last step we need to sort of associate
the menu with the menu button so let's
associate the inside menu with the menu
button
so to do that we just call my underscore
menu
which is the name of our you know menu
button and then inside of here we're
going to assign the menu to it and what
menu are we going to assign we're going
to inside our inside underscore menu
okay so let's go ahead and save this and
run it see if that worked we ran through
that pretty quickly so python menu
button.pi and now when we click on this
boom we see each of these things very
cool but when we click on them nothing
happens so how do we get it well it does
put a little check box next to it so
that's fun so how do we get it to where
you know when we click on a thing it
does something well that's a little
tricky but it's not too bad now normally
we would come over here and we would
assign a command equals something so
let's come up here and create a command
called stuff right and what do we want
to do well we want to
take whatever X that we clicked on
and pass it into here as an X and we
want to do something with it right well
normally you would call stuff
but we also want to pass in that X right
well whenever you want to pass things in
to a function from a button which is
essentially what this is in kinter you
can't just do that you need to create a
Lambda so if we create a Lambda
Lambda and now I know this looks like a
capital l but it's actually a lowercase
you would think that this would work but
it doesn't and I'll show you why so
let's come up here and let's just print
X or better yet let's come down here and
create a label real quick so I'm just
going to call this Miner score label
this is going to be a TV DOT label we
want to put it in root we want the text
to equal nothing right now and then
that's my underscore label dot pack this
guy and give it a pad y of like 40 to
really push it down the screen
but now let's come up here and let's
configure our label so minor Square
label dot config
and we want to set the text equal to X
for now right so let's run this and see
what happens this is not going to
actually work so here when we click on
primary boom it's outline info which is
the last thing if we click on secondary
boom it's outline info which is the last
thing why well think about it as this
thing is looping it adds
X into our
function up here
well it does it for primary primary gets
passed in and it does it for secondary
secondary gets passed in danger info
outline Ally and outline until it comes
to the very last thing outline info it
passes it into the function and then
boom X becomes outline info now we don't
want that it's overriding all the older
ones that went in so how do we change
that well super easy we just come up
here and let's inside of here say x
equals x that's all we have to do that
should fix this so here I'm going to
make a little F string and I'm going to
say U selected X okay so let's save this
and run it and see if that works
it should
so now when we click this thing when I
click primary boom it says you selected
primary when I click info it says boom
you selected info when I select outlying
danger boom you selected outline danger
now this doesn't update yet we have to
change that but at least we're passing
the right thing and this is why I don't
use a variable with this why do we need
a akinter variable we've got the label
we can do things based on that label if
we want we could do any logic we want so
that's just my rant finally we want to
change our my underscore menu we want to
dot config it we want to set the boot
style to X so that will change the
actual color because when we defined our
menu button we set the boot style to
warning so here we can update that boot
style with whatever we clicked on in the
button in the drop down and so that
should be fun so let's run this guy one
more time see if all this worked
so now we click primary boom it changes
to Blue primary secondary Danger
info we got the outlines I like the
outlines the best I think those look
pretty good so outline primary outline
secondary outline danger like that one
outline info so that's it that's menu
button now you can play around with the
size of the text and the colors of the
background and the foreground and all
that using a regular style widget and
I've got videos on style widgets earlier
in the playlist I think the button video
we did we also talked about style so you
can watch that if you want to change the
the backgrounds of this of these things
but uh yeah pretty cool and pretty easy
so that's menu button with ttk bootstrap
and that's all there is to it
in this video we're going to look at the
meter widget in ttk bootstrap this thing
is awesome and very customizable we
could do all kinds of stuff with this
you can see I've got it going up to 120
you could change that to whatever you
want you can see there's these sort of
dotted outline you could also make that
solid you could change the color you
could change the text you can increment
it by any amount here I've got five
percent you can step up by any amount
here I've got ten percent step down you
can do by buttons you could do it by
dragging and dropping and that's we're
gonna look at in this video all right so
I've got a phone I'm just calling it
meter dot pi and it's their basic ttk
bootstrap sort of code that we always
have and you can see we're using the
superhero theme we've imported ttk
bootstrap as TB and the rest is just
basic stuff so all right let's go ahead
and create a meter so I'm going to call
this minor square meter and this is a TV
DOT meter widget and again we're calling
TB dot because we've imported ttk
bootstrap as TB now inside of here there
are tons of attributes that you can play
around with so just to get started we
want to put this in root and let's give
this a boot style of like danger to make
it red and again all your ttk bootstrap
colors are available here so primary
secondary danger info success light dark
all the other ones are available so okay
let's just my underscore meter dot pack
this guy let's give this a pad y of 50
to really push it down screen now one
thing you're probably definitely going
to want is the subtext so let's go
subtext equals and I'm just going to say
um hekinter learned this is a meter on
how much tkinter we have learned so
let's go ahead and save this and just
see what we have right out of the box
here so let's head over to our terminal
in my ctkinter.com directory and let's
run python meter dot pi and when we do
we get this empty zero this empty circle
with a zero in it says decanter alarm so
okay if I click on this nothing actually
happens so we don't have much going on
here if I click on this nothing happens
so first let's play around with being
able to click on this and drag and drop
you have to specifically set that up so
let's come here and I'm just going to
put all these things on separate lines
so they're easier to read and to do that
we type in interactive so do we want to
make it interactive yes we do right so
let me just do this because we're going
to do a lot of these so let's save this
and run this and see what we have here
so now when I click on this I can drag
it and drop it and you can see by
default it goes up to a hundred
and that's very cool so if I leave it
off it just you know stays where it is
so all right that's interesting what if
we want something next to the number so
75 maybe we want to make this 75 percent
or maybe on the left side we want to put
a dollar sign what do we do to change
the basically the label inside the main
label oh we could do that we can just
change the text right
to anything we want so if I wanted a
percentage we could do that we could
also do text left you know if we wanted
a dollar sign we could do that so if we
save this and run it
you can see in tiny little text we get
this dollar sign and percentage sign and
you could play around around with the
font size and we'll look at that maybe a
minute but I'm going to take off that
dollar sign because that's silly but
just keep in mind that's how you would
put that that would be text left
obviously so I'm just going to comment
this one out so we can create a meter
type
by default this is set to full we can
also have it semi so let's go ahead and
save this take a look at what this looks
like
and here you see it's not all complete
right it's just semi so that's a little
weird I'm gonna go ahead and put it back
to full
but
I'm also going to comment
can be
semi
all right we can play around with the
stripe
thickness
and I'm just going to set this to let's
say 10 if we run this now we get the
sort of dashes right so that's cool I
really like the look of that and again
you can change this to any number you
want
you know we could do I don't know 50 to
make it really well let's just see
really big so one two three four five
right
whatever
maybe you want uh just five make it real
skinny right so you get these like
almost tick marks that's cool personally
I like ten but uh
anything you want you can do that we can
change the meter size so let's send this
to 200. if we save this well let's
change it to 400 make it really big
you can see whoa we've got a really big
meter size now
right
that's cool likewise you can make it
smaller by just you know make it get
smaller so I'm gonna put this at uh 200
or so save this run It Go
very nice
and just that easy we can give this
thing some padding right so let's go
padding equals and let's just blow it
out let's say 50.
can't really tell the difference maybe
it's padding on the outside
probably so leave that at 50. we can set
the amount used so let's say we'll set
it to 20. this is sort of like the
default what it is when it starts right
up
all right so by default boom it's just
already at 20. all right so that's
interesting
we can also change the amount total
and let's say I put it at 150. so before
we had it at 100 100 now it's 150 as as
high as it'll go so so if we run this
you can see it's still at 20 by default
if I drag it all the way up 130 140 all
the way up to the top is 150. Right
personally I would always keep it at 100
because you know you're usually doing
like a hundred percent a lot of times
when you're using a meter of some sort
it's a percentage but if you need it for
any other thing that's how you do that
and uh very cool now there are lots of
other things you can play around with
this very quickly let's head over here
to the documentation we could go to
ttkbootestrap.readthedocs.io if you
click on the style guide It's not that
useful come down here to meter it just
shows you basically the basic
functionality so I should mention you
could also change the subtext color and
that's just with subtext Style
so let's just come down here give it a
sub subtext style of let's say I don't
know success something like that save
this run it and now the subtext is
that green success color that is hideous
right so uh let's just give this um I
don't know let's call it dark
let's say light I think that's maybe by
default with this theme
yeah so by default that's light colored
very cool so
like I said there's not much stuff right
here but if you want the information on
this you can go to the API section up
here and then come down here in the
widgets module click on meter and then
here we get the API documentation which
is much more complete so these are all
the things you could play with so Arc
range
you could do amount total we did that
amount used widget size meter size boot
style we did that meter type Fuller semi
we did that meter thickness we did that
show text interactive we looked at that
stripe thickness we looked at that text
left text right text font if you want to
change the font size for the text in the
center you could use that subtext we use
that subtext style we just did that
subtext font again you could change the
size of that if you want so Dash size 10
and then we have step size we'll take a
look at that in just a second so pretty
straightforward that's how to make it
look certain ways now how do we actually
use this so let's say I drag this around
and I end on 78 I need to know that it's
at 78 programmatically how do I do that
how do I know what it's at further how
can I change it by like maybe clicking
on a button to increment it a certain
amount how can we do that well let's
take a look at that now real quick super
easy and let's come down here and let's
create some buttons so I'm going to call
my underscore button and this is going
to be a TV DOT button we want to put it
in root we'll have the text to say click
me
and let's say
five right
so we want to click it and move the
thing five so let's give this a command
of clicker I don't know and that's my
underscore button dot pack this guy give
it a pad y of 20 push down screen a
little bit and now let's create this
clicker function now first
let's just there's several there's a
couple different ways you could step it
up or down or you could set the amount
used attribute of the wages so if we
want to just create a counter real quick
Let's Go Global
counter and let's also just really
quickly set this up here Global counter
and let's set the counter equal to five
or something to start out with and then
inside of here
let's say my underscore meter
dot configure and then we want to set
the amount used to our counter and then
every time we click it we want to
increment our counter so let's go plus
equals five right now if we want to keep
track of that let's keep track on the
button so that's my underscore button
dot configure and let's set the text
equal to Let's create an F string and
let's say click me
and then inside of here let's pass my
underscore meter so to see what the
meter is actually set on at any given
time you can call the amount used VAR so
this is a variable
and this needs to be a period so this is
a variable sort of like a kinter
variable that will keep track of this so
to get it we need to dot get the amount
used for so okay that looks pretty good
except oh this should be amount used not
amount user anyway all right so let's go
ahead and save this and run it see how
this looks okay so we started at 20 we
want to click me five boom it goes to
five percent now it does not go to 25
because we just didn't program it to do
that we could easily have set the
counter at 20 to start with and then
incremented at 5 but we didn't do that
anyway you get the idea 5 10 15 20 25 30
35 40 45 50. all the way up now if we
hit 100 and keep going this will just
keep going so it keeps spinning right so
we can programmatically fix that if we
want and also let's set our counter at
20. just because and then to fix that we
would just come into our thing here and
let's just say what let's go if counter
is less than or equal to 100 then do all
this stuff and I'm just going to tab it
all over all right that looks good oh
let's save this and run it we start at
20 boom it goes to 25
30. all the way up to 9500 we keep
clicking at 100 it doesn't go past 100.
so that's one way you can do that so
that's how to sort of increment it
manually if you just want to set the
amount used and you could do that
there's nothing wrong with that there's
sometimes you probably would want to do
that but there are even better ways to
do that we can step so let's grab this
and let's copy and paste a couple more
buttons in here and I'm gonna call this
my button two and my button three so
then here as our text instead of Click
me five let's say Step Up
and
here instead of Click me five let's say
step down and let's give this command of
up and let's give this one a command of
down so all right let's go up and create
these two functions
so let's define up
and let's define down
so here we can step up in any amount so
let's just go my underscore meter dot
step and then inside here we pass
however many places we want to step so
if we want to step 10 we could just do
it like that same thing with down it's
the exact same process instead of 10
though it's let's say we want it to go
negative 10. right just that easy and uh
kind of all there is to it now let's
make this a little bit bigger so these
all fit 570 has come back over here and
let's see let's run this guy now one
weird thing about the steps that still
didn't quite fit uh we started at 20 if
we step up from here it'll go backwards
so it goes ten five it's zero now to go
four again in 10 in steps so just sort
of keep that in mind so if we run this
again and we want to step down again it
goes the opposite direction so if we
start actually let's just start at zero
here just to make this easier to follow
so amount used let's put this at zero
okay so now if we run this guy again and
again not quite big enough so if we step
up boom 10 20 34 56 78 90 and then it
just goes back down again
right so we're stepping up now we can
step down boom and this one once it hits
zero it keeps going negative right so
again you could programmatically change
this with an if statement like we just
did with the first function I'll leave
that to you guys so very cool right and
even when we're stepping up and down we
can still grab this guy and move it
around
all right and as always you can still
always no matter which one of these you
you use you can always find whatever the
current thing is like for instance right
now it's 82. we can always grab that
just by referencing this amount used VAR
and then getting it like that so very
cool and uh a lot of fun I don't know
about you guys but this is one of the
things that makes me really like ttk
bootstrap it's these little things that
have been added that aren't a part of
regular kinter this meter thing is
really cool I mean you can do all kinds
of cool stuff with this and it's really
easy to use and very configurable as we
could see we could change all kinds of
stuff with this and it's pretty easy to
use
in this video we're going to be looking
at notebook tabs with ttk bootstrap and
this is what we're doing here we've got
these little tabs here and on each one
we can have different stuff and we can
style them different ways and all that
good stuff and that's what we're going
to look at in this video so we've got
our basic starter code that we've always
got I'm calling it MB dot pi and we're
importing ttk bootstrap we've pip
installed that obviously and we're using
the superhero theme so let's come down
here and create our notebook now these
things are tabs but it's called a
notebook so it's kind of weird we're
just going to name this my underscore
notebook
and this is going to be a TB dot
and it's TB here because we're importing
ttk bootstrap as TB and we just want to
put this in our root window and let's
get this a boot style of and I'm going
to give this blue style of dark now you
can use all your boot style colors for
this primary secondary info success
danger dark light and all that so keep
that in mind and that's really all we
need to do now that's my underscore
notebook dot pack this guy and I'll give
this a pad y of like 20 to kind of push
it down screen a little bit so the trick
to this thing is you add frames as the
tabs right so you create a frame you put
whatever you want in that frame and then
you add that frame to The Notebook so
let's create a frame I'm going to call
it tab one right and this is going to be
a TB dot frame you can also use a
regular Kinder frame but it's going to
be kinder colored so we want to use
tp.frame and we want to put this in my
underscore notebook so I'm going to copy
this and let's create a second one and
I'm going to call it tab 2. so we've got
these two frames now we just need to put
stuff in them so let's just play around
with this I'm going to create a label
this is going to be a label we want to
put it in tab one right so the text is
going to say my awesome
label
all right it's a very awesome label and
you know just for fun let's give this a
font of and let's say helvetica
and like a size of 18 to make it nice
and big and then we could just my
underscore label dot pack this guy and
let's give this a pad y of like 20 push
it down screen inside the frame a little
bit and then we could play around with
this let's create a text box I don't
know this is going to be my text and
it's going to equal a regular text box
now notice this is not a ttk bootstrap
text box just a regular text box that's
fine uh we can put it in tab one
as well
and let's give it a width of like 70 and
a height of like 10 just to sort of
expand it a little and again we can my
underscore text Dot pack this guy
and I'm going to give it a pad y of like
10 maybe a pad X of ten two just for fun
mix it up and finally let's create a
button just one little button and this
is going to be a TB dot button
we want to put it in tab one again
and want the text to say click me
or something like that
and let's give this a boot style
of like danger and outline so it'll be
red outlined okay and then finally
that's my underscore button dot pack
this guy and give it a pad y of like 20
push it down screen a little bit so
we've got our first tab our first frame
filled out now let's create our second
one and I'm not gonna be as elaborate
with the second one let's just create a
label in fact I'm just going to come up
here and copy this guy
and instead of calling it my label let's
call it my label one or probably my
label two would make more sense and then
this is going to say
this is tab two all right capitalize
that
and instead of putting it in tab one
right here let's put it in tab two so
okay that looks good now let's add our
frames
to The Notebook
now we haven't added them yet so we've
got this tab one and tab two and to add
them we call my underscore notebook
dot add and then we just say hey tab one
and we want to give this some text so
I'm just going to say tab one
let me copy this guy paste it again call
tab two and on this one we're gonna call
Tab 2. right and that's it so this text
is the little text that's going to be on
the little tab at the top of our
notebook a little panel thing uh so
there we go all right that looks pretty
good let's head over to our terminal I'm
in my ctkenter.com directory and let's
try on python
NB dot pi and boom here we go so we've
got tab one and tab two inside of tab
one we've got our label we've got our
text field we've got our button that
doesn't actually do anything but it
looks good and tab two we have just some
text that says this is tab two now I've
got this set to the Dark theme for this
notebook and this looks pretty good
right so when you click a tab it
highlights otherwise it's sort of muted
and dark I like that but you can use all
of your boot Styles so if we come up
here to where we Define this thing
instead of dark if we want to say info
for instance I don't really like the
boot style colors with this and you'll
see why here
see here it is now it looks like Tab 2
is highlighted like we've selected Tab 2
but we haven't it's the one that hasn't
been selected yet but it's the one with
color so it doesn't really make sense
when we click on it we're now on tab two
it says this is tab two but tab one is
the one that sort of looks like it's
highlighted so it's it's very confusing
and it's not just this boot style it's
any of them that you pick so if we
change this to danger for instance we're
gonna get the same sort of weird thing
going on the non
tabbed tab is the one that's highlighted
which you know is kind of weird so I
just sort of keep that in mind I get
around that myself by just using you
know dark or light uh it's still going
to get the same thing with light if we
see here let's look at this but it's not
quite as bad right let me click on this
it's still in my mind isn't great now
you might be thinking what if we call
like danger outline what happens there
well
we're getting there so you can't do that
it would be kind of fun if you did if
you could but uh no so I'll keep this at
dark go ahead and save this we'll take
one more look at this I think that looks
pretty good
and very neat
in this video we're going to look at
progress bars and they're very similar
to The Floodgate we looked at a few
videos ago and you can see we've got
this progress bar I've got it set to
striped you could also set it to solid
and we've got it sort of the green color
and we can increment a few things at a
time we can stop we can do auto every
second boom boom I've got it moving 20
and that's kind of cool we can just go
automatically Zoop like that and keeps
going and going all kinds of cool things
you could do with this and that's what
we're going to look at in this video so
I've got some basic starter code of
calling it PB dot Pi short for Progress
bar I guess and uh we're importing ttk
bootstrap as TB I've pip install that
and we're using the superhero theme so
it's that sort of Dark theme so okay
let's just come down here and create a
progress bar I'm going to call it my
progress this is going to be a TB dot
progress bar and it's TV DOT because up
here we imported ttk bootstrap as TB so
there we go and now there's all kinds of
different attributes you can use for
this thing we'll just sort to start
walking through all of them here we want
to put this in root we want to give this
a boot style of you know anything you
want so let's say danger that's the red
color you can use all your ttk bootstrap
colors for this so primary secondary
info success danger light dark all the
rest of them so we'll just do danger
that's that red one and that's solid you
can do striped if you want just by
passing a striped but for now let's just
do solid see how that looks now like I
said we can change all kinds of things
here so we can start out by setting the
maximum length so let's go maximum and
let me just put these all on separate
lines so we can read them easier and I
just want to make this a hundred if you
wanted to make it 200 that's the maximum
sort of number it can go to so from zero
to 200 from 0 to 100 whatever I'm just
going to put 0 to 100 we can also change
the mode so just like the flood gauge
thing we looked at a few videos ago we
can set the mode Now the default is
determinate
and the other option is indeterminate
we'll look at both of those we'll set it
to determine it for now you don't have
to put the mode on there if you don't
put the mode it'll just be determinant
by default but we're going to play with
it so I'm going to put it on there and
let's see what else we got we can change
the length of it like how physically big
it is so I want to say length equals
let's say make it 200 nice and sort of
long now that's not to be confused with
the maximum so it might be a length of
200 like you know that big versus a
length of 100 versus a link of 50 so
it's 200 but it still only goes to 100
it's just the you know the bar will be
physically bigger right and we can set
the value to start with so if we want to
set this to like 20 right out the box we
could do that so let's go ahead and my
underscore progress
dot pack this guy give it a pad y of
like 40. really push it down the screen
let's just save this and run it see what
we got here so we head over to my
terminal I'm in my ctkinther.com
directory and let's run pythonpb dot pi
and when we do we get this solid red bar
you can see it's 20 because we set the
value to 20. so it's already got 20 on
there and you can see it's you know yay
length so that's kind of cool we can
make it bigger we can make it smaller so
that's cool so let's go back here very
quickly and let's just change this just
so you see to 300 and let's set the
value to Zero by default on the sky
again see now it's much longer the
length of it is an additional 100 so
that just makes it bigger so okay now
what can we do with this thing so let's
create some buttons so first I'm going
to create a frame real quick to put
these buttons in so let's call this
minor score frame
this is going to be a TV DOT frame
and we want to just put it in root and
then that's my underscore frame dot pack
this guy give them a pad y of like 20
push down screen a little bit so let's
say for aim and let's say progress
bar
and then let's come down here and create
some buttons
so I'm gonna call this minor score
button
this is going to be a TB dot button we
want to put it in my underscore frame
I also have the text say
increment 20.
and let's give this a boot Style
of
I don't know info make it blue or
something I don't know hey let's also
give this a command of uh increment
so let me copy this we'll need to create
this function in a second and for now
it's my underscore button
dot grid this guy so we'll grit this in
the frame and we'll give it a column
of 0 and a row of zero and for good
measure let's give this a pad X of 10 to
space it apart from the other buttons
we're about to create so let's come up
here and let's create this function
let's say increment
20 and so I'm going to Define increment
now let's say we want to increment this
by 20. now there's a couple of different
ways to do it I'm going to suggest an
alternate way than the sort of standard
way you might think so the standard way
is just to call you my progress dot step
and then say how much you want to
increment it so we could just do that
this doesn't work great though as we'll
see here so let's come back over here
let's run this guy our button is blue if
we click this boom it goes up 20 40 60
80 100 oh it goes back to zero it
doesn't stay at 100 when you use step
and to me that's kind of annoying when
it gets to the end I want it to stay
filled out at the end so I can see it's
done right it's just sort of in my mind
that should be the way it works it
shouldn't just go back to zero it's very
unsatisfying right you get to 80 and
then instead of Boom all the way closing
it just disappears so I don't love this
so I tend to not use the step method
here so let's go ahead and get rid of
that what you can do is call the value
so let's go minerscore progress and then
pass in the value attribute and then we
could just plus equal 20. so it takes
whatever the value is currently starts
out at zero and it adds 20 to that so if
we save that come back over here run
this guy now every time we click this
it's just going to add 20 20 40 60 80
100 it gets to the end it's all filled
out it looks great I like it to be
filled out at the end like that it just
makes sense to me does it make sense to
you it should be filled out at the end
so I tend to use this method now uh it's
pretty cool and that's pretty easy now
let's create a quick label down here so
that we can get the current value
so let's come down here and let's just
uh create
a label and I'm going to call this
underscore label
this is going to be a TV DOT label I'm
going to put it in root want the text to
equal nothing to begin with and uh we'll
just leave the boot style off for now
because we don't really care what it
looks like and let's dot pack this guy
give him a pad why of 20 to push down
screen a little bit so now if we want to
Output what the current value of our
progress bar is how could we do that
well we come up here and let's just get
current value
so that's going to be minor Square label
dot config
and we want to set the text equal
to whatever our current my progress bar
is and we just pass in that same value
attribute right so every time we click
the button it will increase it by 20 and
then output that onto the screen so if
we save this and run it so we get boom
it says 20 down there 40 60 80 100 very
cool now I can barely read that so we're
going to make this a little bigger just
for fun let's come down here and let's
give this guy a font equal to like
helvetica
and size 18. so okay that's cool so
that's just increasing it you know
buy a certain amount right so we've set
it to 20. we could set this to any
number we want ten five one zero well
not zero but you get the idea so very
cool very quickly let's change this to
120. so the maximum is 120 just to sort
of differentiate this and the length
right so if we run this real quick we're
just going to see of course the the
length of it's the same but now it goes
20 40 60 80 100 120 right so the maximum
has changed so I just wanted to point
that out in case there's any confusion
there I'm going to change this back to
100 so all right what else can we do
well we can have this thing
automatically start and just go before
we do that though let's look at this
determinant thing right so if you want
to do indeterminate what this will do is
well one it'll change the the shape of
it and let's change this from danger to
Danger striped just for fun it'll change
the shape of the progress bar how it's
filled it'll just make a little line but
it'll also continue so once you get to
100 it'll then go back down again so
indeterminate means it goes up and down
which you may want for certain things so
if we run this we could see that
right after that you can see it's
different because it starts out with
something and then 20 40 60 80 100 click
it again boom goes down to 120 140 161.8
it just keeps adding right
because we're adding in our function if
you wanted to have it hit 100 and then
go back down to zero you could do some
logic to do that
um I don't think we're gonna do that
that's basic logic you would do that in
here once you just run a if statement if
value equals 100 then you know instead
of this plus equal 20 it would be
minus equal 20 right so you could do
that but you get the idea so okay that's
determined kind of weird I don't use it
all that much but there are certain
circumstances you may need to use it so
what else can we do well let's have a
button where we can click it and it just
goes right it just kind of like
starts at zero one to the other nine ten
eleven all the way up to 100 very
quickly so let's come down here I'm
going to create this I'm gonna grab this
button and let's go
let's grab a couple of these so I'm
gonna go my button one one two two three
three we'll set this one to say Auto
and let me take this command off for now
this one will be stop
and this one will be
start
and again let me take this command off
and for start let's create a command
called start and we'll create this
function in just a second we also need
to change these columns so this would be
column one column two and column three
so okay let's come up here and let's
create
just start
so let's define our start function and
here we could call our progress bar so
my progress and then we could just say
dot start and then we can pass in the
increments that we want it to move so
let's say 10 right so if I save this and
run it and I click Start it goes all the
way up and then we're still in
indeterminate so it just will keep going
back and forth right so if we close this
let's change this back to determinant
save this and run it now when we click
Start it just goes Zoop and it just it
keeps going now you could set some logic
in here that says hey if it ever hits
100 stop but uh I'll leave that to you
how do we get it to stop if we want to
we've got this stop button it doesn't do
anything well let's look at that right
now so let's come down here to our start
button or to our stop button and let's
give this a command of stop
we come up here
let's create a stop function
so we Define stop
and to stop this guy we just call my
underscore progress dot stop pretty
simple so if we save this and run it
we can start it and boom stop it just
goes back to zero start stop same thing
here we can increment 24 to 60 80 we
click stop boom it goes back to zero now
this doesn't update after that
because our stop function doesn't have
that on there but you could put that in
there if you wanted I suppose you could
just grab this
and I'll put it right there so
very cool and uh pretty easy now what if
you wanted to Auto increment at a
certain interval based on a certain time
well we could do that let's come up here
to this Auto button and let's create a
command called Auto
and to do this we're going to use the
python time Library so let's import time
it just comes with python we don't have
to install it or anything we can just
import it and let's come down here
and let's Auto
so Define Auto
and I'm going to create a for Loop so
let's go 4X in a range of say five so we
want to do 20 increment blocks so 20 40
60 80 100 there's five of those in a
hundred right so we're going to Loop
through five times right so we can just
uh grab this guy right here
and and paste him in so that will do
that and we also probably want to Output
our current value so we'll do that and
then we can time
dot sleep and we want this to happen
every second now if we run this this
isn't actually going to work uh let's
see if we run this so if we click Auto
it just sort of the whole program
freezes until it finishes so in five
seconds boom there it goes now that's
not what you want at all we want it we
want to see the progress as it goes
right so to do that we have to call
something I don't know if I've talked
about this
definitely not on this channel we can
call Root dot update underscore idle
tasks
and this is just a function that will do
what it says it will update the idle
task so instead of waiting until the
thing is completely done it'll do them
one at a time so we could say uh update
one at a time
not all at once or something like that
and here we could say uh increment
one second
time whatever so now if we save this and
come back over here
it'll go one two three four five you
know every second boom it will do that
so that's kind of cool I like that when
we stop it still does that here we can
uh still doesn't like that
and this starts over as well just keeps
going as you click it you're going to
want to put some logic in there that
stops IT at 100. I'll leave that to you
it's trivial so very cool very easy to
use not a whole lot of options here you
set the maximum you set the link you set
the current value you can get this value
anytime you want just by calling value
like this and you can assign things to
that value just by using a assignment
operator like any old Python and you can
set this mode to determine it versus
indeterminate whatever floats your boat
and uh very cool
in this video we're going to look at
radio buttons for ttk bootstrap now
we're going to look at the actual
buttons these round things we're also
going to look at radio buttons like the
actual buttons here so you can click and
it'll go from one to the other they act
in the same way as radio buttons but
they look like actual buttons so that's
what we're going to be looking at in
this video so I've got some basic
starter code that we've always got I'm
calling it rad dot Pi sure for radio I
guess radio button whatever we're
importing ttk bootstrap as TBF pip
installed that already and we're using
the superhero theme so let's come down
here there's a few different ways to
make radio buttons and I'll show you a
couple different ways in this videos but
I like to create a python list that'll
have all the things that I want to make
buttons for and we just Loop through
that and create buttons for each one but
I'll show you a more manual way to do it
also later on in this video so let's uh
create radio button list so I'm going to
create a list called toppings and this
is going to be pizza toppings or
something so let's go pepperoni and
we'll just do a few of these we also
want cheese pizza and and we also want
what veggie pizza or something like that
so it's just a basic python list nothing
really interesting to see here but now
we also need to create akinter
variable keep track of everything so we
want to know when you click on a button
which button you've clicked on so we
need to enter variable for that and
Kendra has these special variables you
can have string vars or int bars we're
going to use a string bar for this so
I'm going to call this my underscore
topping
and we're going to set this equal to a
string VAR
just like that and that's all there is
to it so now let's Loop through the list
and create radio buttons so let's go for
topping in toppings
right so remember Toppings is our python
list we're going to Loop through it for
each topping in there what do we want to
do well let's create a TB dot radio
button
and notice the B and button is lowercase
I have a tendency to want to make it
uppercase but it's lowercase and we want
to put this in root and now we have to
pick a boot style
and just like everything in ttk
bootstrap you can use all your basic
boot style styles so primary secondary
info danger uh dark light all the things
so let's create uh let's do danger so
danger is red so we'll create red ones
and then now we need to set a variable
well we know what our variable is we've
defined it right here as my topping so
let's pop that in there now we also want
to designate the text what is going to
say on the actual radio button itself
what text should it be well I think it
should be topping
right so for pepperoni it'll say
pepperoni for cheese it'll say cheese
for for veggie it'll say veggie now like
I said there's lots of different ways
you could do this you can use a list of
tuples and then you know have a
different name and a different thing you
know so instead of pepperoni it might be
pepperoni and one cheese and two veggie
and three you know so you might put the
name here and the the variable there
like I said there's lots of different
ways to do radio buttons they all work
with bootstrap so we're going to do it
this way and we also need to set the
value the value will also be topping
so whenever somebody clicks on it what
do we put in this variable well we put
whatever that topping is right so my
topping the variable will become
pepperoni my topping the variable will
become cheese
Etc so okay that looks good now we can
also dot pack this right here if we want
give this a pad while like 20 push down
the screen a little bit
and that looks good now notice we didn't
name this we didn't go like my
underscore button equals like we
normally would since We're looping
through here we don't need to do that
and since each of these have a variable
we don't need to distinguish between
each one they're all going to be the
same right so if we click on one that
means definitionally the other ones
can't be clicked on that's what a radio
button is you can only click on one at a
time so we can do it this way so okay
that looks good now there's a couple of
different ways to figure out which one
you've clicked on you can either create
a button and then whenever you click
that button it'll sort of like submit it
and then you can do something or you can
add a command right to the radio button
we're going to do both here just so I
could show you kind of uh how to do that
so let's create button and let's just
call it my underscore button
this is going to be a TB dot button we
want to put it in root I want the text
to say something like
click me all right and let's give this a
command of
uh clicker right so we're gonna click
the button and run this clicker function
so before we do that let's my underscore
button dot pack this guy put it on the
screen give it a pad y20 kind of push it
down screen a little bit
so while we're at it let's also create a
label so we can output when we click on
something we can output it on the screen
hey you clicked on whatever pepperoni
right so I'm gonna call this Miner score
label it's going to be a TB dot label we
want it to be in root and we want the
text to start out saying you selected
colon nothing right so then let's go
minerscore label dot pack give this guy
a pad y20 push down screen a little bit
okay so now we've got this clicker
function we need to create so let's come
up here and create it so let's go
clicker function
and let's define Clicker
and here we just want to change the
label so let's go minerscore label dot
config and we want the text to say let's
create an F string and let's say U
selected
and then let's put in a variable so what
variable well it's this variable right
here right our string bar variable so we
want to
uh my underscore toppings dot get this
right and that's a function so put your
brackets there so that's all there is to
it let's go ahead and save this and run
it make sure that worked so head over to
our terminal I'm in my cetkinter.com
directory and let's run Python rad.5 and
when we do we get pepperoni cheese
veggie that looks good you selected
nothing when I click on veggie you can
see it's red because we selected danger
the boot style of danger is red right
now if we click this button it says use
selected veggie and we're good to go
that's all there is to it so cheese
cheese pepperoni so that's awesome very
easy but what if you don't want to use a
button right what if you just want to
click cheese and have it automatically
update well very very simple so let's
come down here and right here in our
button we've given it a command of
clicker we can just take that thing and
apply it to the radio button itself so
come up here inside of our radio button
pop that in there command equals clicker
save it head back over here run this guy
one more time and now when we click
cheese boom it says you selected geez
very cool you selected pepperoni so just
depending on the flow of your program
what you need it to do you might want to
have a button so if somebody's like
filling out a form or something and
there are other things in the form you
want them to fill out name email address
whatever you probably don't want them to
click this button and then boom it
submit the form right you would want to
click this button select pepperoni
finish filling out the rest of the form
and then click a order button or
whatever boom then it says pepperoni so
you could use either way just depends on
what you're doing so okay that's cool so
now we've got these things working but
when it comes to radio buttons there are
actually buttons too These are nice
little round things you could sort of
toggle but you could do the same thing
with buttons themselves so how do we do
that well I'll show you how to do that
right now and there's actually two
different styles you can use in
bootstrap to do that so let's come back
over to our code
and let's uh create actual radio buttons
radio button buttons there we go actual
radio button buttons all right so this
is a good way for me to also show you a
second method to do radio buttons you
know up here we created a list of all of
the buttons we wanted and then we looped
through it here wow that might be overly
complicated if you've only got one or
two things you want as your radio button
thing so you might want to just create
the manually so how do you do that well
we can we could do that I'm going to
call it radio button one and radio
button two and we'll just set that equal
to a TB Dot
radio button just like before and we
want to put it in root now we make them
into actual buttons with a boot style so
let's set the boot style equal to and
let's change up the color I'm going to
call this info color but to make it an
actual button we call the tool button
boot style and that will create an
actual button and we have to do the same
thing as the other radio buttons we have
to set a variable so let's set that
equal to minor Square topping again
because remember up here we did the same
thing right we also need to set a text
what is the button going to say well I'm
just going to say radio
button one right there we go
we also need a value right so I'm just
going to say uh radio button one
and we also need to give this a command
of clicker so when we click on it we
want to run that clicker function right
so I'm going to copy this whole thing
and we actually also need to rb1 dot
pack this guy give it a pad y of 20. now
I did this on its own line you could
also do it at the end of it but nah I
like to do it on their own lines when
you're doing them manually so all right
let me get rid of that and paste this
thing in again and let's call this rb2
and this is also going to be a tool
button
we can also do the second style of ttk
bootstrap tool button and that is an
outline so I'll show you both of them
this one is just tool button this is
tool button and outline right so again
same variable but instead of radio
button one we want it to say radio
button two and for the value it also
wants to be radio button two okay so
let's rb2. hack this guy make sure we
put him on the screen give them a pad
white of 20 to push down screen a little
bit save this head back over here run
this guy one more time and now we have
two buttons down here and they're actual
buttons and it's the info color this
sort of light blue this one is the
regular one it's solid right when you
hover over it it changes to dark blue
this one is outlined when you hover over
it it changes like that but it's
outlined otherwise so that's kind of
cool and the same thing occurs if we
click this one it says you selected Rio
button one and this one is unselected if
we click this one boom it says here at
radio button two and this one gets
unselected because with the radio
buttons you can only have one at a time
likewise if we come up here and click
cheese boom these two buttons both
become unselected because these are all
the same radio button series I guess you
would call it and again it says you
selected G so veggie cheese pepperoni
radio button one veggie radio button two
cheese whatever you like all the
different things and that's all there is
to it so those are radio buttons with
ttk bootstrap very simple very
straightforward just remember you use
the same sort of functionality as a
regular kinter radio button the only
real difference is you had a boot style
and it changes the color otherwise you
just treat them like any other radio
button in kinter and there you go
we're gonna look at sliders with ttk
bootstrap and these are technically
called scales but that's silly it's a
slider I know it's a slider you know
it's a slider this is a slider but of
course it's called scale and this we're
gonna look at in this video so you can
see we can move this back and forth and
when we do the number changes down here
uh we can make these horizontal we can
make them vertical we change the colors
we can do all kinds of fun things and
that's what we're going to look at in
this video so I've got a file I'm just
calling it slider.pi because this is a
slider not a scale
it's a scale but anyway we've got our
basic starter code that we've always got
we've imported ttk bootstrap as TB at
pip install ttk bootstrap way back at
the beginning of this course and you can
see we're using the superhero theme so
to use a scale let's just create a scale
slash slider I'm going to call them
sliders but they're technically scales
and let's just call this minor score
scale and it's going to be a TB dot
scale
and we want to put it in a root and we
want the boot style to be any of the
colors that you want to use so we've got
primary secondary warning info danger
dark light all the regular boot style
styles and I'm just gonna go uh warning
now we can set all kinds of different
options and attributes for this we'll
get into that in a second for now I just
want to put this on the screen and take
a look at it so minor score scale dot
pack let's give this a pad y of like 50
to really push it down screen so let's
head over to our terminal real quick I'm
in my ctkencher.com directory and let's
run Python's slider.pi and when we do we
get this little slider it moves back and
forth and you know it doesn't really do
anything right now but it's on the
screen and it is glorious we have a
slider so okay let's look at some of the
attributes we could play around with
here and we can come down here I'm just
going to put a comma and put these each
On Their Own Line first we can give this
a length now I know this kind of looks
like a capital l this is a lowercase L
Sublime just does that and we can set
this to anything we want now this is the
physical link so you know it was like
this big before
200 would be twice as big right so we
could save this run it take a look and
see what that looks like and now
suddenly the slider is twice as big now
that does not mean it goes from zero to
200 this is just the physical length
it's just like 200 think of it as pixels
200 pixels right I mean we could get
crazy with this
and why not let's make this let's go
400. oh yeah that's right so now we see
it goes all the way the length of this
thing almost very cool so all right
that's length very useful we can also
set the orientation so that's just
Orient
and by default it is horizontal that's
you know side to side we can also change
this to vertical
go ahead and save this
might even be too big for our app nope
and now it goes up and down down and up
all right so okay that's cool I'm gonna
go ahead and change this back because
because I find that annoying the
horizontal so side to side now if you
wanted to go side to side you don't have
to put Orient equals horizontal
obviously because we did that earlier it
defaults to horizontal just by default
so okay now we can set the from and the
two so you know what do we want to start
at zero maybe or 10 or 50 or 100 or
whatever you wanted to start at and we
use the from underscore attribute and
it's from underscore because from is a
like a python keyword so we can't use
from so it's from underscore I'm going
to set this to zero and then we could
set the two equal to whatever we want so
100 200 whatever I'm gonna put it at 100
for now now we can't actually see this
yet because we don't have anything to
see what the scale is so let's fix that
real quick let's create a label and I'm
going to call this Miner score label and
it's going to be a TV DOT label we just
want to put this in root we want the
text to equal nothing to start out with
and let's underscore label dot pack this
guy put him onto the screen and now what
we could do is give this scale a command
sort of like a button when you press it
so I'm going to call this command scalar
I don't know whatever so now we can
create that function to do something
every time we move the slider around so
let's define scalar and now a normal
function you don't have to do anything
but with this you have to pass in an
event because every time you move the
slider around that will push an event
into this function and the event that
it's pushing is the position so whatever
it happens to be that's what it'll be so
what do we want to do well let's change
the minderscore label dot config let's
change the text on that to something
else well what do we want to change it
to let's change it to minor Square scale
dot get and that will allow us to get
the current position and then output it
to the latest let's go ahead and save
this and run it now remember we've set
it from zero to a hundred so that's sort
of interesting
if we run this guy and we grab this
you'll see well first that's very little
but it's
10.36294
300518134 right that's a very long
decimal number and we don't love that so
but you will notice
it goes from zero zero point zero all
the way up to 100.0 so that looks good
so first let's come down here to our
label and let's give this a font of
say helvetica
and like size 18 make it nice and bigger
now also let's take off this from in
this too
so if we run this again
you're going to notice that we didn't
set a from in two so now it's just from
0 to 1. and it's all these very very
long decimal numbers so what can we do
here well first let's give this back up
from zero to one but now we can come up
here and wrap our myscale.get in the int
function this is just the python integer
function this will convert anything into
an integer so if we do that and run it
that should get rid of all the decimal
point numbers and just give us one two
three four five seven nine ten up to
100. very cool so
moving right along
let's change this to 500. right now
again this won't change the physical
length of the slider this is the from to
two so now it goes up to 500 right
oh
so you might be thinking well okay
that's great to put these numbers on the
screen but what if we want to actually
do something based on where the slider
is well of course then you would just do
it in this function right so instead of
putting this label thing here you might
say you know if uh my underscore scale
dot get is less than 50 you know do
something else do something else right
you would do logic in there so that's
how you would do that so okay moving
right along we can change this I'm going
to put this back to 100 because scales
should go from 0 to 100 in my mind right
zero to a hundred percent that sort of
makes sense and we could change this
around if we wanted to get fancy put a
little percentage sign there if we run
this I'm just messing around now for fun
oh it's outside of the quotation mark
put it in the quotation mark
see getting sloppy
all right so save this and run it now it
very fancily says 74 percent all right I
don't know totally useless but fun
nonetheless so what else can we do with
this well the only other really
interesting thing there are some other
things you could do with this but the
only really interesting thing is you
could set the state to disabled
right so if we save this and run it
now it doesn't work at all and if you
wanted to enable this you would create a
button or something that when you
clicked it it would set this to normal
right so normal or disabled those are
the two options there and again if we
run this guy one more time
now it's enabled again and we can play
with our glorious slider once again
and that's all there is to it so that's
the slider pretty easy
scale that's the scale pretty easy I
don't know why they call it a scale it's
obviously a slider but uh yeah pretty
fun
in this video we're going to look at the
scroll bar with ttk bootstrap and
there's several different things we can
do with this we can make it sort of
square we can make it kind of rounded we
can change the color and do all the
things that's we're going to look at in
this video so I've got a file I'm just
calling it scroller.pi and it's our
basic Kinder starter code that we always
have we've imported ttk bootstrap as TB
I pip installed that many videos ago in
the series we're using the superhero
theme and that's pretty much it so let's
start out by creating a basic frame so
I'm going to call this my underscore
frame and this is going to be a TB dot
frame though I suppose you could use a
regular Kinder frame because we're not
actually going to look at this we want
to put it in root and it's just going to
be used as a container to hold the
things to put a scroll bar in so we're
not really going to see it or anything
so it could be a ttk bootstrap frame or
a regular Kinder frame really doesn't
matter and so it's my underscore frame
dot pack this guy let's give it a pad y
of like 20 push down screen a little bit
so okay now let's create a scroll bar
and I'm going to call this my underscore
scroll
and this is going to be a TB dot scroll
bar
and we want to put it in my underscore
frame right so here we can give this an
Orient of
let's say vertical we want it to go up
and down right otherwise it would be
horizontal and here's where we can do
some different things let's give this a
boot style of and you can use all your
regular boost styles with this primary
secondary light dark info success danger
whatever color you want all the Regular
Boot styles that we've looked at in all
these other videos in the series so you
know whatever you like there let's go
danger to make it red and annoying
looking I don't know you could put it I
would probably use dark with this
superhero theme but I'll just do danger
for now just to make it obnoxious and uh
funny looking now the only other option
you have as far as boot Styles is you
can leave it like this and it'll just be
a square scroll bar like a normal
default scroll bar or you could make it
round and it'll be slightly rounded so
we'll we'll do round for now maybe we'll
play with this in a minute so okay now
we need to pack this guys let's go
monitor scroll down pack and we want to
put this on the side of let's say the
right side and let's give it a fill of Y
so Y is up and down vertical
okay so now let's just uh create
a text widget so we have something that
we can you know scroll right let's go
text widget and I'm just going to call
this Miner score text and this is going
to be a regular text widget because I'm
not sure there is one with ttk bootstrap
but it doesn't matter we're just gonna
use a regular text widget and we want to
put this in my underscore frame
and let's give this a width of like I
don't know 30 and like a height of 25
and now here the important thing is and
let me put this on another line we want
a y scroll command of underscore scroll
dot set
and let's also give this a wrap of none
so there's no word wrapping inside the
text box and while we're at it let's
give it a font of helvetica and like a
size of 18 so the font's nice and big so
this y scroll command will set our my
scroll scroll bar this guy right here as
the scroll bar for this widget right
this is just basic hinter scroll bar
stuff has nothing to do with ttk
bootstrap you would do this for any sort
of scroll bar using regular kinter or
ttk or this or anything else so all
right that looks good so now let's minor
Square text
that pack this guy
and I don't think I want to give it any
sort of padding because we don't want
the frame to show here we just want the
text widget to show so we won't give it
any padding okay so finally we need to
config the scroll bar once we've created
it we always need to then config it so
let's go my underscore scroll dot config
and let's give this a command of my
underscore text Dot y View
and that'll sort of associate our scroll
bar with our text widget right so here
we set it and here we give it a command
so that whenever we move it it knows to
move this guy right here so okay let's
go ahead and save this and run it head
over to our terminal I'm in my
ctcincter.com directory and let's run
Python scroller.pi and when we do we get
this annoying red scroll bar and if we
type some stuff here we could see the
scroll bar moves and we can scroll and
notice it has a slight roundedness to it
right
so that's cool if we want to take that
off we can come up here to our boot
style and our scroll when we defined it
and just take off that round if we save
this and run it you see now we have just
the regular sort of default Square
scroll bar
whatever you like
that's pretty cool so let's play around
with this very quickly one more time
instead of Danger let's change this to
dark and I want to bring that round back
and this is probably what I would do if
I was actually making an app using this
color scheme because I don't know I
think that looks kind of modern and cool
having it dark like that and there we go
so that's a scroll bar now if you wanted
to change this into you know sort of
down here
horizontal you would just change your
Orient to vertical and this instead of Y
it would be X and instead of
this y view it would be x view right so
Y is up and down X is left and right
that's really all there is to it also
this instead of Y scroll command it
would be obviously X scroll Command
right so basically just change all the
Y's to x's and you've got yourself a
horizontal scroll bar instead of a
vertical one so those are scroll bars
with ttk bootstrap very easy very cool
and uh pretty fun
in this video we're going to look at the
separator this line thing here and the
size grip this little dotted thing in
the corner here that allows us to do
this and that's what we're going to be
looking at in this video so I've got a
file I'm just calling it sep.pi short
for separator.pi I guess and we're
importing ttk bootstrap as TB at pip
installed that long ago in this series
uh we're using the superhero theme and
that's pretty much it so let's come down
here and let's create a label real quick
I'm just going to call it label one and
it's going to be a TV DOT label and it's
TB because we imported ttk bootstrap as
TB and we just want to put this in root
let's just have the text say label one
no big deal let's give this a boot style
of I don't know let's say light and
let's label one dot pack this guy
give it a pad y of like 40 really push
it down the screen so I'm going to grab
this and I'm going to copy and make
another one and we'll call this one
label two and this will just say label
two so in between these we want a
separator those separate tour so I'm
gonna call this my underscore sep
and it's going to be a TBE dot separator
and we want to put it in root and here
the main thing that you can do with this
is give it a boot style and this allows
you to change the color of the separator
that line right and that's really all a
separator is it's just a line and so you
can use all your regular boot Styles
dark light primary secondary info
success danger any other ones I forgot
so I'm just going to make this danger so
it's red and nice and easy to see let's
go my underscore sup dot pack and we're
going to play around with this a little
bit more because there's a couple of
things you can do with this but for now
let's just save this and run it make
sure this looks okay let's head over to
our terminal I'm at myctkinter.com
directory and let's run
pythoncept.pi and when we do we get
label one label two and this tiny little
separator now you'll notice it's very
small by default and it's actually a
little hard to change the size of this
I'll show you how to do it but it's not
as easy as you might think or hope or
expect it to be so let's first before we
do that there is one main thing we can
change about this we can change the
Orient so by default it is horizontal
right and you don't have to do Orient
equals horizontal obviously we just saw
that by default it's already horizontal
but if you want it to go up and down you
just change it to Vertical so if we save
this and run it now we have it going up
and down right so okay that's cool I'm
gonna go ahead and change this back to
horizontal now the question becomes how
do we change the size of this thing and
when you're using pack we can change it
to fill equals
x and x is left to right if you were
doing this vertical up and down you
would change this to Y right but we're
doing it horizontal we'll put fill
equals x now if you do this you'll
notice we run this it stretches the
entire size of the app which may be what
you want maybe not so how do we change
the size from not very little or very
big but some other measure how do we do
that now normally with kinter you would
use a width attribute so you would come
up here and you would just say you know
with equals 200 or something and that'd
be good to go not so with the separator
with that we need to use pad X so pad X
gives padding on either side on the
x-axis right so if we gave it a pad X of
let's say 10 that would take just a
little bit off of each side right so if
we run this you can see just a little
bit off the edge it doesn't go all the
way to the end right so we would have to
play around with this based on whatever
you want so if you gave it say 100 and
think of these as pixels 100 pixels
see now it's you know got 100 on each
side so just play around with that and
uh you know get it to the size you want
it's not a great method but it's sort of
what we have right so that's the
separator very simple the only other
option is just change the boot style
right and uh so instead of danger maybe
we would say info right so save this and
run it ooh ah now it's sort of light
blue all right so okay that's the
separator now let's look at the size
grip and I don't find this to be all
that popular
but you may find some use for it so
we'll look at it real quick let's create
this guy I'm going to call this my
underscore size grip
very original this is going to be a TB
dot size grip
we want to put it in root and same thing
you can give this a boot style of
whatever you want so I'm just going to
stick with the same color scheme here so
info will make it info color that light
blue and that's pretty much it so now if
we my underscore size grip.pack this guy
and just put it on the screen we can see
if this worked and we see it's right
here in the middle of our app because
that's where we packed it right but if
you grab this and sort of hold your
mouse button down you can resize it from
there now of course you could also do it
from the corner
but Back in the Day apps used to have
these little grippy things on the corner
and so if you're old enough you'll
remember that maybe you put the size
grip thing in the corner or for some
weird reason you need to resize your app
from inside of the app like this and you
just want to put your size grip right in
the middle of the screen that's how you
do that but how can we put this in the
corner well we're packing this guy so we
would have to use anchor and the pack
statement here so I would put this in
the Southeast Corner SE so South is all
the way down east is all the way over
right and then that will sort of get us
there if we save this and run it it
won't quite work you'll see it it puts
it over here but that's not you know
exactly what we want we want it down in
this corner so
what we could do is give this a fill
equals both and then make sure it's
expanded so we could go expand equals
true
so that should jam it down into the
bottom right corner if we run this sure
enough there it is now we can do that
and it looks like it should
and we're good to go so I put two
widgets in this video we usually just do
one widget per video but you know these
are kind of lame widgets the size grip
you're never going to use that you might
but I've never used it I've been using
kinter for years and years and years
I've never actually used a size grip
same thing with a separator you might
use a separator there might be some
visual reason for you to put a line in
your app very easy to use though and
that's all there is to it
in this video we're going to look at
spin boxes and this is a spin box you
can see you can just click it and sort
of spin through each one uh we can have
it where when we click the button this
label changes or we can have it whenever
we just spin it the label changes as
well and that's what we're going to look
at in this video so I've got a file here
I'm just calling it spinner.pi it's our
basic enter starter code and I've
imported ttk bootstrap as TB I pip
installed that many videos ago we're
using the superhero theme and that's
pretty much all there is to it so let's
start out by creating a spin box so I'm
gonna go spin box
and I'm going to call this Miner score
Spin and this is going to be a TB dot
spin box
and it's TB dot because we imported ttk
bootstrap as TB and we want to put this
in root and we want to give this a boot
style and here you can use all the
different boot style colors that we've
looked at in all the other videos in
this series so primary secondary info
success danger warning light dark all
those things uh let's just go success
here make it nice and green and weird
and then that's my underscore spin dot
pack this guy
and give it a pad y of like 20. now
there are several different things you
can do with this first let's make this a
little bit bigger let's give this a font
of helvetica
and a size of 18 so it's nice and big
and we can see this now also I'm going
to put this on a separate line so it's
easier to read you can do spin boxes a
couple of different ways you can have
words and other things in there or you
can have numbers so we'll start out just
with numbers so if you want to designate
a range you could just go from
underscore equals and let's start at
zero and let's go to let's say 10 right
so that's really all we have to do let's
go ahead and save this and run it head
over to our terminal I'm in my
ctkinter.com directory and let's go
python spinner dot pi and when we do we
see right away we get this sort of empty
looking spin box it's not empty if we
actually click it it starts at zero and
then it goes to one two three four five
six seven eight nine and ten all right
so we can go back down again and back up
again so that's to and from and now
you'll notice when we started this there
was nothing listed here I'll talk about
that in just a minute too but before we
do that let's look at the other way to
do this using words so
here let's go spin box list and here we
can just create a python list I'm just
going to call it stuff because you know
I have no imagination and let's go John
and April and Bob and Mary so in order
to use these we just use a values tag
and set that equal to our stuff right
one thing to note when you add a value
it will override your from and two so we
can leave that on there it'll just
override it so here let's go ahead and
save this and run it and when we do we
click this now it says John April Bob
and Mary so one thing you'll notice like
I said it's blank when it starts and
also the text seems to be highlighted
what's up with that well with spin boxes
you can delete the thing that's in there
and add your own thing right you just
type it in so now it's John April Bob
Mary and Tim all right so that's one
sort of weird thing about spin boxes
personally I've never found a use for
that but I don't know maybe you would
find some sort of use for that but we
can disable that if we want by setting
the state of the spin box so let's come
down here and set a state of and let's
set this to read only so now when we run
this we won't be able to change it
anymore by typing but also you'll notice
it's not highlighted right so if I click
on this and hit delete and try to type
something in nothing happens right so
that may be what you want as a default
sort of thing I usually would use that
for my spin boxes because I don't want
people changing them at runtime so
that's kind of interesting now what
about this thing where when we run this
it starts off being blank well maybe
that's what you want maybe not you can
set the value of this if you want head
back over to our code and let's set the
value
let's say set spin box default
and we're actually going to need to do
this underneath the spin box because we
can't set a default before we've created
a spin box so here we just call my
underscore Spin and we can not set this
guy and you can set this to anything you
want so I'm going to set this to John by
default so that's the first item in our
list so that's what I want to set it as
by default so now when we come back over
here and run this guy
boom right off the bat John is listed
and we can cycle back up all the way
through it spin up spin down all the
good things very cool so okay that's
cool but how do we decide if something
has been selected
and by selected I mean it's the thing
showing in the spin box right now so for
instance April how do we get April out
of here somebody has spun up to April
well we can dot get our thing so there's
a couple of different ways to do this
let's create a button and it's just
going to be my underscore button
and it's going to be TB dot button
we want to put it in root we want the
text
to equal click me and we want the boot
style to be that same success green and
then let's minor square button dot pack
this guy
give it pad y 20 push down screen a
little bit now here we want to give this
also a command and I'm going to call
this spinny
right
and so now we can come up here to the
top and create this function so let's
define spinny
and here we can do something but first
let's come down here and let's create a
label
so this is going to be my underscore
it's going to be a TV DOT label
we want to put it in root we want the
text to equal nothing right off the bat
and let's give this a font of
alvetica and like a size 18 so it's
bigger so that we can read it and then
let's my underscore label dot pack this
guy give him a pad y of 20 push down the
screen so now what we want to happen is
when we click this button we want to
change the text of this label to
whatever is in the spin box well to do
that we just come up here to our
function and we might underscore label
dot config this guy
and we can set the text equal to my
underscore spin
dot get
and many things in Canter you can dot
get them and same thing with spinbox so
that's cool you can also set a string
VAR to your spin box and get that but I
find that sort of useless it's just an
extra step so what I'll do is I'll just
myspin.get whatever the spin box is so
let's go back here run this guy one more
time and here if we click me for John
boom it says John there if we spin it up
to Bob and click it boom it says Bob if
we hit Mary boom Mary
and not to leave out April boom April so
that's how you can use a button and our
button is blue it's interesting I
thought we put that as
success oh I misspelled success boom
there we go so that works for the button
but what if you don't want to use a
button what if you just want to use the
spin box itself well you can give your
spin box a command so let's put this on
another line and we can just call our
spinny function same exact function or
you can use a different function really
doesn't matter so now when we run this
guy hopefully our button is green yes it
is instead of clicking the button if I
just spin this up to April boom it says
April when I click this thing again boom
Bob so it's the actual little spin box
toggle things that determine
when the function gets called when that
command runs right
and there we go so that's spinbox pretty
easy pretty straightforward not a whole
lot of bells and whistles here
personally I don't really use the spin
box all that much but it certainly has a
place in some apps and if you need it
that's how you use it piece cake
okay in this video like I said we're
gonna look at the tree view for ttk
bootstrap and I'm not going to get into
the tree view in great detail I've got
other videos on that I'm going to take
some of my older videos that I did on
the tree View and uh put them into one
big video and I'll post that in a few
days so if you want to get into a deep
dive on the tree view you could look at
that but for now I'm just going to show
you how to make a basic Tree View how to
do the ttk bootstrap styling and stuff
that you would expect for this thing and
that's what we're going to look at in
this video so here we've got a tree View
and you can see it's just this box thing
with rows and columns and we got first
name last name email address I just kept
it very simple we got some dummy data
first name one last name one email one
Etc so that's what we're gonna look at
in this video so we've got a file I'm
calling it tree underscore review.pi
it's our basic interest order code we've
imported ttk bootstrap as TB as always
we pip installed that long ago we're
using the superhero theme and that's
pretty much all there is to it so let's
go ahead and just Define The Columns
that we want in our tree View and I'm
just going to call this columns and this
is just going to be a little Tuple here
and we want first underscore name
then we want last underscore name and
then let's just go email
so very simple all there is to it so now
let's create a simple tree view so I'm
going to call this minor Square tree
and it's going to be TB dot Tree View
and it's TB dot because up here we
imported ttk bootstrap as TB and here we
just want to put this in root and we
want to select a boot style and these
are the same boost style colors that
we've used for all the ttk bootstrap
widgets right so you have primary
secondary success info warning danger
light dark all the things so I'm just
gonna go success so that's that green
color
and then we want to set the columns to
whatever our columns are going to be
well right here we defined our columns
as columns so we're going to set columns
equal to columns and here let me put
this on another line we want to show and
we want to show the headings
now this will show you know the headings
at the top of each column which we
haven't actually defined yet but that'll
do that so okay that looks good so now
we're we want to show these headings we
have to define the headings right so
let's go my underscore tree dot heading
and then here we just designate each
column so the first one is first
underscore name that's this thing right
here but then we put a comma and then
the text for that heading is going to be
what let's go first name so you notice
this is more like a variable name and
this is more like the text that's going
to show on the tree view so you know
it's capitalized got a space in there
looks nicer right so let me just copy
this and we'll do this a couple more
times so we have first name we also have
last name
and here I'll change this to last name
and then this one will be email
and I'll switch the text for this to
email address make it look nice and
pretty okay so that looks good so now
let's create some sample data right now
normally you would have real data but
you know we don't have any real data
this is just a tutorial so I'm going to
go ahead and create some so let's create
a python list that's empty and now let's
fill it with some fake data so let's go
four in in range of 1 through 20. so
we're gonna have 20 rows right and then
for each row we want contacts dot append
and it's
contacts.append because well let's
change this to contacts all right so
we're going to append into this empty
python list what do we want to append
well let's create a list here so let's
choose F strings and
for each one I'm going to say the first
name and then just
pass in a number
so that'll be n that's this guy right
here so for each one of these so the
first time we Loop through this the N
will be one the second time we Loop
through this the N will be two three
four five every time we live through
here this n will change so this will
allow the data that shows up on the tree
view to be first one first two first
three for each row right so all right
that looks good for that now we also
need to do the same thing for last
so let's go last in and we also need to
do the same thing for email so let's go
email
and at
address.com right
all right so just some basic dummy data
we'll cycle through and do 20 rows of
that so now all of this fake data has
been appended to this python list now we
just need to put that list on our tree
view right so we can do that right here
and let's do another loop let's go for
contact in contacts
right and it's contacts because that's
the name of our list here
contact singular because we just make
that one up that's how loops work and
then let's go my underscore tree dot
insert
and we want to put this at the zeroth
spot so from zero to end and then what
value do we want
well whatever that contact is
okay
so all right that's really kind of all
there is to it let's go ahead and save
this and run it let's head over to our
terminal and then my cetkinter.com
directory and let's run python tree
underscore view dot pi and you know what
we forgot to pack our tree view onto the
screen why didn't you remind me so let's
see where we created our tree view right
here we obviously need two minor Square
tree that pack this guy let's give this
a pad y 20 push down screen a little bit
so all right that should work now head
back over to our terminal run this guy
again and there we go and that's all
there is to it right so we've got first
one first two first three we can use our
Mouse little scroll button to scroll
down this guy and there we go so here we
have our columns first name last name
email and everything looks great now
this whole thing is green because that's
the Boost style we selected right so we
could go danger right save this run it
and now we've got the nice red horribly
ugly right tribute so that's really all
there is to it now like I said we're not
going to dive deep into how to use tree
views because with ttk bootstrap you
just use your tree view like you would
in a regular kinter widget right just
use all the same attributes that the
regular Kinder widget treeview has and
uh you're good to go so there's nothing
specific to ttk bootstrap that you need
to change except adding a boot style to
change the color basically right and
like I said I'll put I'll try and put
together a deep dive of the tree view
because it's really interesting I could
do 40 or 50 videos on it alone there's
all kinds of cool stuff you could do
with it in fact I have in past videos on
my other codemy.com channel so I'll put
together a bunch of those videos and one
big video uploaded to this channel
sometime in the next few days or so if
you're interested in doing a deep dive
on the tree view then of course if you
wanted to make it into a ttk bootstrap
preview you just do what we did in this
video to use a ttk bootstrap preview
in this video we're going to look at
message boxes for ttk bootstrap so we
click this button boom a little box pops
up it's got a little message a little
title a little icon we can click yes or
no if we click no hey you click no if we
try it again and click yes hey you click
yes now there are a bunch of these
different dialog boxes that you can use
you can ask questions you can show
warnings you can give info all that
stuff we're gonna look at all of that in
this video so I've got our basic starter
code that we've always got we're using
the superhero theme we've imported ttk
bootstrap as TB we pimp installed that
many videos ago and the first thing we
need to do here is import something so
let's go from ttk bootstrap dot
dialogues so this is basically a dialog
box right so we want to import message
box now there are other things you can
import like message dialogue
we don't need that for this video but
it's a similar sort of pop-up box and
maybe we'll talk about that in another
video so okay now the next thing you're
going to notice is this root icon bitmap
now this is the little icon that shows
up when we run this file so if we say
this I'm calling this Mbox dot Pi head
over to our terminal I'm in my
ctcinter.com directory and let's run
python Mbox dot Pi that icon is this
little icon right up here we've
designated that's the icon right so when
we have a message box pop up it will
have its own icon but it'll just show
the default ttk bootstrap icon unless
you make a little bit of a change right
here so we need to copy this line and
let me say uh message box icon here and
it's the same exact code we just studied
a default equal to this right now you
might think hey do we need this line
anymore yeah we do we can comment this
out and if we run this again we're going
to get no icon basically here just the
default thing right so we have to keep
both of these lines it's really kind of
weird I I have no idea why that's the
case uh but let's say right here main
app icon and then here we've got the
message box icon so okay that's good so
now let's build out this app so let's
create a button I'm just going to call
it my button it's going to be a TB dot
button
we're going to put it in root we want
the text to say click me
and let's give this a boot style
of I don't know danger to make it red
and a command of
I don't know clicker all right so so
every time this button gets pressed we
want to run the function clicker so we
don't have that yet we'll create that in
just a second but for now it's my
underscore button dot pack put this guy
on the screen let's give this a pad y of
40 to really push it down the screen so
there's our button and here we need to
Define our clicker function here and
we'll do that in just a second now I
also want to create a quick little label
so I'm going to call this Miner score
label this is going to be a TB dot label
we want to put it in root we want the
text to equal nothing for now and let's
give this a font of I don't know like
helvetica size 18 just to make it bigger
so that we can read it easier and then
let's minor Square label
dot pack and I don't know give this a
pad YF 20 push it down the screen a
little bit probably don't need to do
that but okay so now we've got this
function called clicker and every time
you press this button we call this
function so what do we want to do well
let's
create
a dialogue
so I'm going to call this MD short for
message dialog or MB short for message
box whatever it doesn't really matter at
all and this is going to be a message
box now here we have to designate what
type of message box we want so uh let's
go yes no there's like I don't know
eight or nine of these will go over all
of them in a second but for now we'll
just do yes no and let's create a list
of these so let's go yes no and I'll add
these as we go through them all so here
we could say uh display
some message here this is going to be
the message that pops up in the middle
of the box so whatever you want to
display in your message box type it in
there and then here
is the title so this will go on the
title bar up at the top right so okay
that looks good now for now let's just
run this and see what we have so let's
save this head back over to our code run
this guy again so here we've got this
thing we click it boom it says display
some message here here's the title
you'll notice there's our little icon up
there and we have a yes or no well if we
click no what happens well we don't know
yet so what does happen well let's come
down here and uh display button click
right so let's go my underscore label
dot config
and we want to set the text equal to
and I'm just going to create an F string
and then I'm going to say you clicked
and then inside of here we're just going
to go MB so whatever you clicked here
will get assigned to this variable and
it will output right there so let's go
ahead and save this head back over here
run this guy again so we click me so now
when we click yes it says you click yes
when you click no it says you click no
right so basically if you click yeah no
it's returning the word n o capital n o
now this is just a string now you can do
stuff based on that right so you could
do an if statement right so let's go if
MB equals no
then you know we could print no or
whatever you wanted to do else you would
you know print
yes like whatever you wanted to do you
could do
right there right so let me just comment
all this out because it's kind of silly
but this is just an example of how you
can do stuff logically based on what the
person selects right now each of these
things we're going to talk about yes no
is the first one there's lots of
different message boxes each one returns
a different thing so you have to know
what it returns in order to do your if
else logic correctly and we'll see that
in just a second so all right but for
now I'm just going to
let's copy this
and just
we'll just print out you clicked
whatever just to see what each of these
things do so okay the first one was yes
no we looked at that one the next one is
okay right so we'll just type in message
box dot okay if we save this guy and run
it and click here now it says the button
is just okay if we click this it says
you click none now this actually Returns
the word none right so it's a string
it's just none you would dig your logic
if you know MB equals none do this else
do something else right so okay that's
kind of interesting I guess the next one
is okay cancel
so let's come down here and okay cancel
you'll never guess what this one does
right maybe you will guess it does okay
or cancel right so if you click OK it
says you clicked OK if you click cancel
it says you click cancel right so it's
returning okay or cancel all right so
that's okay cancel
now obviously whatever you want to do in
your app that's going to determine which
of these you use right if you want to
give the user the ability to cancel or
click OK you would use OK cancel if you
want them to answer a question yes or no
you would use yes or no right if you
just want to give them a message and
have them close it you might just use
okay right it just determines it just
depends on what you're trying to do in
your app right so okay the next one is
show info
so actually this is show underscore info
in regular kinter it's show info without
an underscore and in ttk bootstrap for
some reason it's show underscore info
I'm not sure what's going on there but
that's what it is
so again we can come up here and here it
says displace the message here but it
has this little icon this little info
right you're showing info this is the
little info icon right and if you click
OK it returns none so okay maybe you
want the little icon info icon to pop up
if so you would use show info right we
also have show error
all right so this one's actually kind of
interesting right uh because if you know
if you're doing error handling in your
app and you want to show an error that's
popped up you would probably want to use
this and this is nice because
I don't know if you could hear that or
not it made a little ding it went dating
a little warning Ding and it also has
this big red X like warning right so
that's interesting if we click OK it
returns again none so all right that's
cool
so okay that's cool let's show error and
we also have show underscore question
so we can change this one
to show underscore question
save this guy go to the screen it's
getting unruly run this guy again and
here we get this little question mark
and we get yes or no now if we click yes
here it says yes if we click no it says
no again you'll hear you'll hear maybe
you'll pick it up on the microphone
a little Ding and ding right so that's
what that does so all right that's cool
oh that was interesting let's run that
again
I probably should have mentioned that if
you click yes it returns yes if you
return click no it returns no if you
come up here and click the little X it
does none so keep that in mind that's
the case for all of them as well so okay
that's cool I'll start another line here
and the next one is show underscore
warning
show underscore warning is very similar
to show underscore error so let's run
show underscore warning
save this guy
run them again
but instead of a big red X you get this
sort of uh warning like uh for like uh
almost like a traffic sign but with an
exclamation mark and when we click OK
it's none I'm gonna click the X here it
also returns none so all right so we've
got one two three four five six seven I
feel like there's one or two more so
what about what else do we have so we
did yes no we also have yes no cancel
so this is very much like yes no yes no
cancel
but instead of two buttons you have
three buttons which is kind of
interesting
so if we run this guy we get yes no and
cancel if we click yes you click yes we
click no you click no if we click cancel
we get cancel and again if we click the
X we get none so all right that's
interesting finally one more we have
retry and cancel
all right so this is kind of interesting
we have retry cancel
and I'm guessing you could probably
guess what this one's gonna do all right
it's not rocket science here we have
retry and cancel and if we click retry
it Returns the word retry and if we
click cancel it Returns the word cancel
so that's pretty much it
and none if you click the little X in
the top so those are message boxes very
very useful very cool very easy to do
and uh it's kind of all there is to it
if you want to learn more about these
you can go to let's see
ttkbootstrap.readthedocs.io and click on
API and then come down here to message
box and it has each of them listed here
so here's the okay one here's the okay
cancel one and it has all the different
little attributes you can play around
with right whether the ring whether to
ring the bell or not the title The
Message we've already did those two so
you can come through here and read all
these if you're interested but we pretty
much hit the main points and that's all
there is to it
in this video we're going to look at the
color Chooser for ttk bootstrap and
that's this guy right here you can see
oh it's very neat looking and if you can
click on this boom it'll pick a color
give you all the data we can click OK
and now we're going to change our color
to that color let's change it to Blue
whatever it doesn't matter what you do
with the color that you choose that's
kind of irrelevant but I'll show you how
to get the actual information you can
see the RGB value and the hex code and
all that good stuff so that's we're
going to look at in this video so I've
got a file I'm just calling it CC dot Pi
short for color Chooser I guess dot Pi
answer basic interest art code that
we've been using we've imported ttk
bootstrap as TB we've installed that
many videos ago and we're using the
superhero theme so let's come down here
and I'm just going to create a quick
button real quick I'm going to call it
my underscore button and it's going to
be a TV DOT button we want to put it in
root we want the text to say click me
all right uh let's give it a boot style
of danger to make it red just for fun
and let's give it a command of of CC
short for colored Chooser I guess right
and we don't have this function yet
we'll create it in just a second so
that's my underscore button and Dot pack
this guy put it on the screen and let's
give this a pad y of like 40 to really
push it down the screen now underneath
this I want a label so I'm going to call
this my underscore label just so that I
can show you the output of the color
Chooser what it returns so for now let's
just create this as a TB dot label put
it in root and give it a text of nothing
for now and actually let's make this
font bigger so it's easier to read so
I'm going to make this helvetica and
like a size 18. so okay let's go my
underscore label yeah pack this guy and
give it a pad why like 10 push down
screen a little bit so okay now we've
got all this set up let's define our CC
function color Chooser and call it
anything you want I'm just calling it CC
so in order to use the color Chooser
first we have to actually import it up
here at the top of the screen so let's
go from ttk bootstrap dot dial logs
because technically this is a dialog box
it's a little box that pops up right and
then dot color chooser
we want to import color Chooser dialog
and you'll notice the capitalization the
C is capitalized this C is capitalized
and this D is capitalized so color
Chooser dialog and now that will allow
us to use it now it's kind of weird
since we're kind of importing everything
from ttk bootstrap why do we have to
import these dialogues separately I
don't know you just have to right that's
how that works and so let's create a
color Chooser so I'm going to call it my
underscore color call it anything you
want and this is going to be a color
Chooser dialog all right now in order to
show this onto the screen have it pop up
we call my underscore color dot show all
right and that will show it so strictly
speaking this will work but it won't
really do anything after you know we run
it so let's save it and run just to make
sure this is working headed back over to
our terminal I'm in my cetkinter.com
directory and let's run python cc.5 when
we do we get this thing oh it says
message box we have to change the title
we could click this hey it pops up
that's great but if we click on one of
these colors and click OK nothing
happens it's not actually returning
anything so how do we get it to actually
return something well first let's come
up here and change this to color or
Chooser for the title right and let's
come down here and to capture what it
returns we can create a variable or we
could just call a function so let me
comment this create color chooser
and then Show color chooser
and then here let's say return color
Chooser info
all right so how do we do that well
let's just create a variable call it
colors and we're going to set this equal
to my underscore color which is our
color Chooser what we defined right here
and then dot result
now this will return three things and
I'll show you what those three things
are in just a second but for now let's
output
to the label so remember we have this
label called my underscore label so
let's dot config this guy and set the
text equal to Colors whatever is
returned here right so let's go ahead
and save this and run see what we got
here so we click this and let's pick a
nice screen now you'll notice it returns
Hue saturation and Luminosity hsl it
also returns red green blue RGB right
you've probably heard of RGB and color
things in the past that stands for red
green blue it also Returns the hex code
now this hex code is useful this is
really what you want the hex code
because anytime you're using colors you
want the hex code right if you want to
change a color use the hex code I mean
you could use these things too but
they're not commonly used for that but
just for now let's just click OK and see
what it returns and you'll notice it
returns a string of numbers now that's
not that useful let's come up here and
pick the most top rightest color and
that's Hue of 0 150 red of 255 green of
0 0 and uh this hex color code so now
when we click this you can see it
returns these three things and if we run
this again
and click on this again and you can see
the RGB is the first one so 255 0 and 0.
that's this column right here 255 0 and
0. then we have hsl 0 150 0 150 and
finally we have the hex color code
ff000 ff0 so that's cool but how do we
get each of these individual things it's
returning three of them how do we get
each individual one well super easy
there's a little function you can call
but instead of calling colors you can
call the thing you want so say for
instance dot hex so here let's go dot
hex
Dot hsl and Dot RGB so here if we just
want the dot hex we can do that save
this run it here let's click click the
red again and boom it's just returning
that hex right so if we wanted the RGB
instead of dot hex we would call Dot RGB
all right so if we save this and run it
I know very exciting if we click this
pick this color again it's just
returning to 255 0 and 0. same for hsl
we could just go you know hsl
and that will return the hsl so I like
the hex you're almost always going to
use the hex so that's what we want to
return now let's change the background
color of our app to chosen color right
so let's just be goofy and play around
with this we could just root dot
configure and set the background to
you know whatever we want so colors dot
hex whatever we're returning here so
let's go and save this and run it this
is kind of a goofy example of why you
might want to use this but I don't know
you could do it like this and let's
change this to this pink whoa there we
go our background is now pink we could
do orange
that's orange we could do blue and you
could do this for anything right any
widget you could change the color so if
you wanted to change the color of your
button you'd do the same thing right
just configure your button set the
background color to you know that hex
color code right there
and that's all there is to it so kind of
a goofy example but you know I don't
know there's lots of different things
you would use this for and I can't go
over all of those examples there's
thousands of them so there's just one
little simple example on how to use it
the main thing you really want is just
to understand to get the color code out
of here you're going to call your
colors.x now we went colors.x you could
just as easily instead of creating this
variable right here you could just go
you know uh let's see it's come in here
and go
mycolors.result dot hex
right if you wanted to just string along
an object oriented sort of thing with
this which is our color Chooser right we
called it my color and it returns a
result and that result can be a hex or
an hsl or an RGB right so really either
way that works but I find it cleaner and
easier just to create a variable right
here add this in here and then just call
colors.x to get the hex code
all right this is gonna be a very short
video but a very cool video and that's
because we're gonna look at the scrolled
text widget and that is just what it
sounds like a text widget that is built
in with a scroll bar look at that
right so in the past we had to create an
actual scroll bar widget and add it to a
text box or add it to a frame or add it
to whatever in ttk bootstrap there's
actually a widget built into it that has
a scroll bar right there and you could
do a couple cool things with it you
could hide it you could show it you
could have it you hover your mouse over
it appears or doesn't appear very cool
and very easy to use that's what we're
going to look at in this video now I
don't know 10 videos ago or so I did a
video on scroll bars with ttk bootstrap
and you could use scroll bars in the
normal way that you would with Kinder or
you can if you're using a text widget
you can just use this little trick I'm
about to show you right now so I've got
a file I'm calling it scroll underscore
text Dot pi and we've got our basic ttk
bootstrap starter code that we always
have I've imported gtk bootstrap as TB
we're using the superhero theme and
everything else is pretty much
rudimentary so to use this we actually
have to import it first so let's go from
ttk bootstrap dot scrolled we want to
import scrolled text now you'll notice
the S and the T and scrolled text are
both capitalize everything here is a
lowercase so that's all we have to do we
just have to import it now I know we
imported pretty much everything here in
ttk bootstrap as TB but we still have to
for some reason import this guy as well
so let's come down here and let's create
a text box so text widget
and I'm going to call this my underscore
text and now normally this would be a TB
dot you know text widget but not this
time this time we're calling just
straight up scrolled text and that's
because we imported that right there
right so we want to put this in root and
now we can give this a height of let's
say 20 and a width of like I don't know
110 and let's also give this a wrap of
word this is basic text widget stuff we
want our words to wrap completely we
don't want to get to the end of the line
in the text box and have a word get cut
off mid word and have half the word on
one line and the other half of the word
on the other line below it we want to
wrap the entire word down to the line
below so there we go so really that's
all we need so let's go underscore text
Dot pack let's give this a pad why like
I don't know 15 or so push down screen a
little bit so let's head back over to
our terminal and run this guy I mean my
cetkinter.com directory and let's run
python scroll underscore text fi and we
have a typo because we of course need an
equal to sign there okay so button equal
to sign come back clear the screen run
this guy again all right
and there we go boom you'll notice it
doesn't appear now but if we start to
type and you know we gotta get to the
end and keep going you can see over
there on the right it's adding the
little scroll bar thing and we can
scroll up and down and it is fantastic
and that's all there is to it so there's
one thing I want to show you about this
in addition we can also give this an
auto hide of true now by default Auto
Hide is set to false as we just saw when
we ran it the scroll bar was there even
though we didn't even need it until we
started typing text and then it kind of
you know popped up or whatever if we set
Auto Hide to True head back over here
run this guy
you'll notice there is no scroll bar at
all until I hover over and then it kind
of appears same deal if we start to type
a bunch of stuff
you'll notice the scroll bar isn't
automatically showing up it's been
hidden it's Auto Hide It Auto hide it
it's Auto auto hided and but if we move
our Mouse over boom then it pops up and
we can use it now some people might like
that some people might not personally I
I don't know I don't really care for
that it seems a little confusing uh I
want the scroll bar to just always be
there so what I would do is leave that
off or you could set this to Auto Hide
equals false save this head back over
here run this guy again and we're going
to get just the default thing where the
scroll bar is just already there always
and as you kind of move down
a little scrolly thing appears
and uh very cool so what else can we do
to this well we can use all of our boot
Styles if we want
boot
Style
and you've got all of the boot styles
that we've been talking about throughout
this series primary secondary info
success danger light dark any other ones
that I might have missed and I probably
want to spell boot style right and this
won't change the text box itself but it
will change the scroll bar color so if
we head back over here and run this guy
again now our scroll bar is red because
that's the danger color right
very cool
and very neat now if we head over to the
ttk bootstrap documentation at
ttkbootstrap.readocs.io and then click
on API and let's see here if we scroll
down here
you can see there's a scrawled frame and
a scrolled text if you click on scroll
text you can see some code and some
things here if you want to read more
about this you can see you can add boot
style you can also add padding you'll
notice you can designate vertical or
horizontal bars so you can have a v bar
or an H bar the V bar is default we've
just been looking at that but if you
wanted to add an H Bar for a horizontal
one you could do that let's head back
over here and let's go H bar
equals true and this just takes true or
false it's Boolean so if we come back
over here run this guy again
see now we've got
horizontal and vertical and if we scroll
all the way over
let's see now this one sort of appears
and works very cool so that's the scroll
text widget it's so much easier than
creating a scroll bar and physically
adding it to your text widget or to a
frame or whatever very awesome very easy
to use and that's all there is to it
in this video we want to look at
scrolled frames for ttk bootstrap and
it's very similar to scrolled text boxes
if you saw that video you're probably
good to go on this you're going to pick
this up almost immediately if not it's
going to take like 30 seconds to explain
this should be pretty easy so this is
what we're going to build just a very
simple app with a frame on it that has a
scroll bar and I just threw some buttons
in here just to have something inside of
it and you can see
it Scrolls all right so ttk bootstrap
makes this incredibly easy in the past
with regular Canter you had to create an
actual scroll bar and kind of add it to
a frame it was very sloppy very kind of
hard to do with ttk bootstrap there's a
widget that just comes with it and we
could just use it and it's really easy
so that's we're going to look at in this
video so I've got a file here I'm
calling it scrolled underscore frame dot
pi and it's our basic ttk bootstrap
starter code that we always have I've
imported ttk bootstrap as TB we're using
the superhero theme and everything else
is pretty much normal as usual so really
the only kind of weird thing is we have
to import this scrolled frame in order
to use it so let's go from TGK bootstrap
dot scrolled we want to import scrolled
frame and you'll notice the S and the F
in frame are both capitalized but the
scrolled in this is lowercase so that's
really all we have to do so let's
create a scrolled frame and I'm just
going to call this my underscore frame
and this is going to be a scrolled frame
now normally we would go like TB dot
scrolled frame something like that
right with regular ttk bootstrap but
since we're importing this as scrolled
frame we just use scrolled frame right
there so we want to put this in our root
and just like the scrolled text box you
can set the Auto Hide so I'm just going
to put this to false it's false by
default if you want to actually hide the
little scroll bar until you hover over
it we'll look at that in a minute you
would put true there but otherwise we're
good to go so uh you could also put a
boot stop but I'm just going to leave it
as the default for now we'll play with
that in just a minute so let's go my
underscore frame dot pack and let's give
this a pad y of 15. and let's also give
this a pad X of 15 and just for fun I
want to expand this to basically the
whole size of our app so let's just go
fill equals both and expand
equals yes
so that will pretty much blow it up to
the entire size of our app so in order
to see this in action we need to put
something in it so I'm going to create
some buttons let's create some buttons
and I'm just gonna do a quick for Loop
here so let's go 4X and range and I'm
going to put 20 of these buttons so
we'll put 21 here
and this is just going to be a TV DOT
button we want to put it in my
underscore frame and let's give this a
boot style of what info something like
that change the color to light blue for
the buttons and let's have the text say
and let's make this into an F string and
let's just say I don't know click me
something like that and let's just also
put the count so we'll put X in there
and then let's just pack this guy give
it a pad y of like 10 to space these out
a little bit so okay now normally I
would never ever ever pack on the same
line that we're creating the button but
in this case since we're doing a for
Loop it just sort of makes sense so
let's go ahead and save this and run it
see how this looks so let's head over to
our terminal I'm in my ctcantor.com
directory and let's run python
scrolled underscore frame dot pi and
when we do we see we've got a bunch of
buttons from 0 to 20 and we've got this
Frame and that looks good now this is
sort of transparent it doesn't seem like
there's anything there that's because we
use the default boot style right so we
could change the color of that if you
want so let's do that real quick up here
in our frame let's just give this a boot
style
of I don't know let's go dark so if we
save this head back over here run it
again
now we get a slightly different colored
frame
that's all there is to it so you'll
notice the scroll bar right here that
I'm dragging and dropping that is there
by default because
we set the autohide to false if we set
that to true we could come back over
here run this guy again and now the
scroll bar is gone unless we hover over
it and boom there it is and if we scroll
down and then scroll our Mouse away
again it disappears again so maybe you
like that maybe you don't I'm not a huge
fan of that but uh you know whatever and
like I said we could change the boot
style to anything we want if we wanted
to change this to Danger this is going
to look god-awful but we could change
the whole frame to red
and then the scroll bar is also red it
has little red arrows and things and I
don't like that one bit let's just go
ahead and change that back to dark and
I'm also going to change this back to
false for the Auto Hide so that is
really all there is to it let's go ahead
and save this or you know what let's
change this to light
I don't know just playing around right
now run this again Ah that's not great
looking but whatever
so that's really all there is to it much
easier than the old kinter way of having
to actually create a scroll bar adding
it in setting the configuration stuff it
was just a hassle ttk bootstrap makes
this so much easier so you have your
scrolled frame or your scrolled text box
like we did in the last video it's
basically the same thing but instead of
a frame it's a text box so you can type
words and stuff in it and very very
useful and very cool
in this video we're going to look at
toast messages what are toast messages
well if you look down there
but um there it is right there sort of
the bottom of the screen Fades away we
can click it again a it pops back up
little message little icon next to it
little Windows thing and that's what
we're going to look at so I've got some
basic hinter starter code that we always
have I'm calling it toasty.pi because
we're doing toast messages and we're
importing ttk bootstrap as TB we're
using the superhero theme as we always
do in these videos and everything else
is pretty much the same so in order to
use these we actually have to import
these this is a little extra thing in
ttk bootstrap so we can do that pretty
easily let's just go from ttk bootstrap
dot toast
we want to import toast notification
and notice the T and the N are
capitalized that's kind of important so
let's come down here and let's create
one of these things I'm just going to
call it toast and this is going to be a
toast notification again capital T
capital n and then inside of here we can
give this a title so I'm going to say my
toast title whatever and there's a bunch
of different attributes we can play with
after title obviously we want a message
and we could say this is a toast message
all right
there we go and then we can also set a
duration if we want so this is in
milliseconds so if I want three seconds
that would be three thousand
milliseconds right there we go and we
could also give this an alert this can
be either true or false I'm going to do
true and this will just give a little
ding a little like system Bell whenever
the alert pops up you may want that you
may not I'll put it on there I don't
even know if you can hear it with the
microphone set up here but you know what
a normal Windows system ding is you know
goes ding you know just it'll do that so
we'll put that as true and then finally
you could put a position and this is
going to be a tuple and it takes three
things horizontal vertical and anchor so
if you don't put a position at all if
you leave this completely off it'll just
show up in the bottom right hand corner
of your screen now that's a little bit
of a problem for me because I've got two
monitors set up here and I'm recording
on the left Monitor and the default
monitor is my right monitor so it'll
show up on the right Monitor and you
guys won't be able to see it so I'm
going to move it over 1900
and 15 pixels by 30 pixels and instead
of it being in the bottom right I want
to put it in the bottom left and so
that's the Southwest now for the anchor
position this last thing now this is a
string and it could be all of the normal
sort of directional things in kinter
north south east west Northwest
NorthEast Southwest Southeast
Etc right so all of those normal things
you can use so we'll just put that like
that and that looks good now we need
something to trigger this thing so I'm
just going to create a little button I'm
going to call this my underscore button
and it's going to be a TB dot button we
want to put it in root we want the text
to equal what click me all right and
let's give this a command of I don't
know clicker something like that and
we'll create this function in just a
second for now let's minor square button
dot pack this guy onto the screen and
let's give this a pad y of 40 to really
push it down the screen a little bit
okay so now we can come up here and
let's create that function real quick
that clicker function and in order to
show your toast notification your toast
message you just call the name of it in
this case it's toast
dot show underscore toast and that's a
function and that's all there is to it
so let's head over to our terminal m m i
c tinter.com directory and let's run
Python toast.pi and when we do we've got
this button here if we click it boom it
pops up after three seconds it fades
away now I'm going to do it again
without talking see if you can hear the
little alert ding
probably not but one two three boom it
fades away so that's kind of all there
is to it now we can take out the
duration if we want
to save this and run it see what happens
then we click this 1001 1002 1003 1004
1005 1006 1007 1008 1009 just seems to
be going on and on if we click it it
disappears or if we click somewhere else
in the app nope we have to actually
click the thing itself so if you don't
have a duration it'll just be there kind
of forever right and also we could play
around with the position remember this
is horizontal and vertical so if we want
it to go up more I don't know we can
make this 300 or so
we run this
now it's going to be way up here so you
can position this anywhere you want on a
screen remember your screen isn't like
everybody else's screen so you may want
to keep that in mind when using a
position but you know pretty cool and
you see a mitos title has a title here
and bold we've got this little Windows
icon and pretty simple so remember just
import it up here in this first line
toast notification from TDK
bootstrap.toast I know up here we kind
of imported everything why do we have to
keep importing separate things I don't
know it's just the way it is but uh
pretty simple again just to use it we
call it toast notification got your
title your message your duration let me
uncomment that out alert and position
and of course you don't have to do a
position otherwise it'll just default
into the bottom right hand corner of the
screen I believe yeah uh yeah and that's
all there is to it
all right so that is ttk bootstrap in a
nutshell so I hope you enjoyed this
video if you want to learn more about
ttk bootstrap and kinter in general be
sure to check out myteacinter.com
YouTube channel and of course check out
tkhinter.com think about signing up for
membership there you get all my courses
for one low price and while you're there
be sure to grab a totally free PDF copy
of my kick your widget quick reference
guide book this thing is awesome has all
the kinter widget attributes spelled out
in great detail grab your free copy
today just head over to tkenter.com
forward slash widget-book enter your
email address and I'll send that right
out to you oh yeah I think that's it my
name is John Elder from teakinter.com
and I'll see you in the next video